الشعر العربي الحقيقي: هو الشعر ما قبل الإسلام
كما يقول الناقد: أن الشعر بابه شر، فإذا دخل في الخير ضعف
والله يسامح «ابن رشيق القيرواني»
اللي حط تعريف الشعر أنه كلام موزون مقفًا بقصد
حقيقة أن هذا التعريف للشعر قضى عليه
زعلان على نجيب محفوظ
فيقول: نقلوا صورة مشوهة للمرأة في المجتمع المصري
فصورها فتاة ليل وصورها بالعاهرة وصورها بالعاشقة
أما صورة المرأة المكافحة العفيفة والفلاحة المصرية المجاهدة
لم تكن لها مكان في روايات نجيب محفوظ، كيف تشوف الفكرة؟
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
هذه الحلقة قراءة في التاريخ الأدبي الفني العربي
نبدأ من الشعر الجاهلي، وكيف بدأ وتطور الشعر حينها؟
فالشعر كما يقول ضيفي: لم ينشأ كما هو الآن فجأة
هو تطور معرفي تراكمي
ثم نروح إلى عصر صدر الإسلام اللي كان فيه الشعر والأدب في أضعف حالاته
ثم انحسب أو انسحب إلى الصراعات والأيديولوجيات في عصر الأمويين
وبعدين، كيف تأثر الأدب العربي حينها؟
وكيف تأثر في العصر العباسي مع دخول غير العرب في المجتمع وفي أركان الدولة؟
والترجمة كيف أثرت على الشعراء والأدباء؟
حتى ندخل في الرواية السعودية
اللي يصفها ضيفي بأنها رواية عن الآخر بامتياز
فهي حلقة أدبية بديعة ومميزة مع ضيفي علي بن زعلة
المتخصص في الدراسات الثقافية
قبل أن نبدأ بالحديث عن الفن والأدب والكتابة
استضفت في حلقة سابقة ماتعة مع الصديق العزيز «أحمد العقيل»
سولفنا عن دوافع الكتابة
وناقشنا الكتابة كفعل وجودي ضد الفراغ، زي ما يسميها «أحمد»
وكيف يحول الكاتب تجاربه إلى فن قصصي واقعي؟
فتقدر تشوف الحلقة في الرابط الموجود في وصف هذه الحلقة
شكرًا لراعي الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن لنبدأ
شكرًا أنك جيت والله
والله أنا سعيد
أنا آسف خفت أنك تزعل علينا
من أيش؟
من التأجيل
لا، هي كانت متساوية أنا وحدة وبعدين...
وحدة بوحدة
أنا ما زعلت
البادئ أظلم
يا عبدالرحمن، البادئ أجمل دائمًا
في انتقائية، إذا بدأت بشيء، وما عجب المتلقي يصير أظلم
بس بعدين «خيرهم الذي يبدأ بالسلام» فالتأويل مشكلة
ممكن يكون مشكلة أو لا، صح؟
يقول لك: الأدب...، هو عنف منظم اتجاه الكلام العادي
«جاكوبسون» يقول: عنف موجّه
ذاك اللي يقول...، الزلزال اللي صار في مصر زمان
فجاء شاعر يقول للحاكم: ما زُلزلت مصر من سوءٍ ألم بها
لكنها رقصت من عقلكم طررا
هل زُلزل وقتك وحياتك بعد انتقالك للرياض وللا؟
والله ما أعرف، بس أنا أحس أني...
كم صار لك، شهرين؟
شهرين تقريبًا مو أكثر، وأحس أني تأخرت في اتخاذ الخطوة
«أن تأتي متأخرًا خيرًا من أن لا تأتي أبدًا»
هذا هو، لأن أنا أساسًا أعتبر نفسي من عيال الرياض، إلى حدٍ ما
والوالد، الله يرحمه، كان موجود هنا مع الناس اللي أجوا أيام الطفرة
الهجرة الجماعية من المناطق المختلفة إلى الرياض
بحثًا عن الوظائف والأشياء هذه
واثنين من إخواني وُلدوا في الرياض
ثم رجع الوالد، الله يرحمه، إلى هناك
وولدت أنا في جيزان، لكني درست البكالوريوس، وما بعدها
حتى ما أزعلك، وأقول لك: أن كل دراستي الجامعية وما بعدها كانت في الرياض
فالمدينة عظيمة، ويوم عن يوم تصير من أجمل مدن العالم في نظري
وأي شخص عنده رغبة في تطوير نفسه ممكن
الرياض جدًّا قابلة إنك تكتشف طاقات جديدة عندك
وتلاقي البيئة اللي تناسبك والاهتمامات المشتركة من كل الأطياف
في كل المجالات، ما شاء الله، حتى في الهوايات والاهتمامات العلمية والطباع
والمزاج والقهوة والشاي، تلاقي البيئات هذه موجودة
وهذا أنت شايف الرياض صارت من أجمل مدن الدنيا ولسه...
أبد كمّل واطربني
الوعود كبيرة، بس عارف أن الرياض
بالنسبة لما أحكّيك أن درست فيها البكالوريوس زمان مو قريب
متى زمان؟
ممكن نقول: في منتصف التسعينيات
ما شاء الله
فالوضع مختلف من ناحية أنه جاي من جيزان، وتدرس في الرياض
دائمًا الرياض تجمع...
الجامعات ذاك اليوم ما في إلا «سعود» و«الإمام»
درست في «سعود» وللا «الإمام»؟
درست في «الإمام»
واحنا أهالي جيزان فينا عشرية، وربما تسامح أحيانًا فطري أو تلقائي مع الآخر
فنجي لما تجمّعنا من كل مكان، وحتى من خارج السعودية
في منح كانت لآسيا وأفريقيا، وكل مناطق السعودية
فكان هنا لقاء بين الثقافات والأطباع
فكانت تصير بعض، اللي نسميها العلاقات أحيانًا تكون غير إيجابية
على مستوى مثلًا اللهجة والأفكار النمطية اللي منتشرة عن كل منطقة
يقول لك: هذه المنطقة الفلانية هؤلاء بخلاء، وهؤلاء مدري أيش فيهم
أيش يقولوا عنكم؟
احنا معروفين احنا صفر - سبعة ما فيها كلام
أظن حتى أنت صفر - سبعة يا عبدالرحمن؟
صحيح
بس صفر - سبعة عارف المستويات حقت الطيارة في «ألف وفي...»
احنا صفر - سبعة
فحتى تلك الأيام كان من سوء حظي أو الجيل اللي معنا ذيك المرة
كان في بعض المسلسلات تطلع عن مثلًا الجنوب
لتكون أكثر واقعية يتحدثون بلهجات المنطقة
فيقوم يستغلها زملاؤنا الشباب في أنه مزيد من...
السخرية
الممارسات
بس الإنسان الجيزاني التلقائي والعشري والمنفتح اتجاه الآخر
ما هو بسيط، وعنده أسلحته
لا تنسى أن جيزاني يعني أدب وشعر وأهل اللغة
فكنا ما نرحم بعض
يمكن احنا كلنا في التسعة عشر، وللا عشرين سنة
فنتتبع نقائص بعض، هذا طبيعي
ويمكن هذا جزء من اللي خلى واحد يدرس بعدين
ويهتم بهذه الظواهر الثقافية والاجتماعية
ودرست الاختلافات ما بين الذات والآخر يمكن في آخر أبحاثي
متواضعة أقولها، لكن كان بشيء لافت للنظر
خاصة بلد زي المملكة العربية السعودية بلد التنوع والاختلاف والتعددية
كل منطقة سابقًا قبل الكيان العظيم هذا اللي احنا فيه
في ظل، الله يديمه يا رب، أن الجنوب جنوب والشمال شمال
الحجاز حجاز، ونجد نجد، والشرق شرق
طبيعة ولغة ولهجة وتاريخ وعادات وتقاليد وإرث
فكونه ينجح محاولة سياسية لتوحيد هذه الكائنات كان صعب جدًّا
لولا أعتقد أنه توفيق من الله لذاك الرجل العظيم
الله يرحمه، الملك «عبدالعزيز»
كان وحدة أسطورية وخرافية جدًّا
الحمد لله، اختلفت عليك الرياض في التسعينيات عن اليوم؟
أكيد، الاختلاف شيء طبيعي أتوقع
اللي هو التجربة الإنسانية نفسها أصلًا يُضاف لها أشياء
خاصة في فترة التسعينيات كانت فترة في تحول في العالم كله أساسًا
يمكن بدأت بأكبر انهيار للشيوعية والاتحاد السوفيتي
وبعدها الحرب الباردة
واحنا عندنا في السعودية حرب الخليج
التسعينيات شهدت يمكن تراجع تيار فكري معين في البلد
اللي يُسمى فترة الصحوة
آثار الابتعاث اللي بدأ في السبعينيات والثمانينات جوا المبتعثين
وصار عيالهم، وصاروا هم في المناصب القيادية في البلد أو مؤثرة
فكل هذه الأشياء تصب في الفكر وحركة المجتمع
الطيف والأجواء على قولتهم، وللا المزاج العام للمدينة
بعدما كان مزاج ربما أحادي أو مكوناته بسيطة، أصبح لا في...
غير كذا أساسًا بناء السعودية بعد حرب الخليج صار فيه عودة إلى الداخل
صار في نظرة إلى مين احنا؟
إذا كان هذا سيف العرب صدام حسين
اللي يقول: «سَيفنا كنت تأملْ سيفنا
كيف أهدى قلبنا الجُرح العميقا»
قصيدة لـ«غازي القصيبي» الله يرحمه
هنا بدأ الفرد والمجتمع السعودي ينظر في داخله، مَن نحن؟
إذا كانت الوحدة العربية صارت طعنة عربية
كمل على هذه إلى نهاية التسعينيات
2001 أحداث 11 سبتمبر
اللي فعلًا جعلت الذهنية السعودية تفتش بجدية وقوة في ذاتها
دينيًّا وثقافيًّا واجتماعيًّا وتاريخيًّا ومذهبيًّا وكل شيء
الآداب والفنون كانتا مرآة هذا الشيء
تعرف عبدالرحمن أن الأدب من الحياة وإليها
وهو منتج إنساني ومؤثر ونتيجة، وهو في هذا كله قبل وبعد
مثلًا أيش اللي عبر عنا في فترة حرب الخليج أكثر من القصائد والمقالات والإعلام؟
كان الكلمة واللغة والمقال والروايات اللي ظهرت فيما بعد
أيش اللي عبر عنا في استيعاب التأثرات
تأثر الشباب مثلًا بالطيف العروبي الناصري؟
الأدب والفنون
لما جاءت الصحوة؛ جاءت بمنجزها الأدبي
الروايات من قصائد من أدب إسلامي، ومن هذه الأشياء كلها
وهكذا صار في المراحل اللاحقة
الكلام متشعب في هذا
بس أنت سألتني عن الرياض، أيش اللي اختلف الآن؟
يقول لك: الرياض أساسًا مدينة متنامية
وأي شيء يحصل يمكن في السعودية كلها
صداها الأكبر وصورته الأبرز تظهر في الرياض
لأنه هنا المؤسسة، وهنا مثلًا نقول: النوافذ الكبرى لإطلالة أي فكرة أو منتج
سواءً كان اجتماعي أو ثقافي أو فكري
فالرياض الآن مدينة أكثر تسامح واستيعاب وتعددية
وأكثر احتواء لكل الأطياف، ودعم واعتراف بأحقية كل شخص أن يكون مختلف
هذا ربما أنا أشعر أن القيادة السياسية هذا هدفها ومنظورها من زمان
فاللي أبغى أقول له من غير ما أطول: أن الرياض الآن مدينة عظيمة جدًّا
والمدن العظيمة والكبرى على مدار التاريخ أبرز ما يجعلها أساسًا مدن كبيرة
إيمانها بالتعدد واحتوائها لكثير من المشارب والجنسيات، والتنوع اللي فيها
حتى منتجها أساسًا يكون متنوع
إذا نظرت إلى المدن والحواضر الإسلامية القديمة أو غير الإسلامية
تجدها ليس فقط على أبنائها الجغرافيين فقط
إنما من كل أبناء البلد، ومن الناس اللي من خارجها
أجل ودي نرجع، دامك أنت مشيت شوية في أزمنة مختلفة وأفكار
وأخذت فكرة اللي هي تعبير الإنسان عن ذاته
بس ودي أرجع إلى الأساس
خلنا نبدأ من الإنسان، وهنا بخص الإنسان العربي
بس أكيد هذه فكرة عامة، ليش الإنسان أصلًا مهتم أن يعبر عن ذاته؟
أنا أذكر مقولة لـ«أبو عمر بن العلاء» رواها عنه الجاحظ
يقول: أن الشاعر يُقدّم على الخطيب
الخطابة يبدو أنها شيء رصين
يُمارسه زعيم القبيلة أو الزعيم الحربي أو القائد
لكن قُدّم الشعر على الخطابة لفرط احتياج العرب إليه
الشعر كان احتياج، وليس ترف
وليس من قبيل فقط ترويح عن النفس أو مجرد التعبير، لا
أنا أشعر أن اللغة أساسًا وظيفتها الخام
هي وظيفة تواصلية في الأساس، وهذا موجود عند علماء اللسانيات
أن اللغة وظيفتها وظيفة تواصلية في الأساس قبل الشعر العربي وغيره
تلك النقوش والرسومات اللي على الأحجار أو في الكهوف أو المنحوتات
هي رسالة تواصلية، وفعلًا الإعجاز إنها وصلتنا إلى اليوم
ووجد علماء يتعلمون سواءً الآرامية أو الهيروغليفية أو غيرها من اللغات
ليفسروها، ولنستدل على حقائق ووقائع وأحداث
ولكن قبل هذا كله وصلنا الفن
الفن اللي وصل، وهو رسم الإبل، لكن داخلها رسالة
فالتعبير الإنساني احتياج
احتياج، ليش اختلف بين الناس؟
فتلقى مثلًا العرب واضح أنه الشعر
بعضهم تلقى عندهم منحوتات وبعضهم المسرح وبعضهم الغناء
بس هذا كله سقط، وبقي الشعر أو ما كان في إلا الشعر عند العرب
فليش تختلف هذه الأدوات؟
والله الوصول في وجهة نظري إلى تفسير نهائي في هذا الأمر
وأنا أشعر أنه صعب، وما راح يكون حقيقي أو دقيق
لكن الأمور لا تنشئ...
يعني الشعر العربي ما نشأ بهذه الصورة مباشرةً
هذه ليست الصورة الأولى للشعر
هل معقول أن الشعر وُلد موزون ومُقفى
ما فيه ولا زحاف ولا علة ولا قافية مخرومة؟ لا طبعًا
كيف كان؟
أكيد أن هناك محاولات
ولأن ثقافتنا شفهية كما يُقال؛ راحت ربما
لكن لما تسمع امرؤ القيس يقول: «عوجا عَلى الطَلَلِ المَحيلِ لعلّنا
نبكي الدّيار كما بكى ابن حذام»
من «ابن حذام»؟ ما نعرف عنه شيء أبدًا
في واحد قبل امرؤ القيس بكى على الأطلال
في ناس يقولون: أن السجع كان...
اللي هو الكلام النثري اللي مسجوع هو محاولة أو صورة أولية للشعر
وناس يقولوا: أن حداء الإبل
اللي هو كلمات إيقاعية أو جمل إيقاعية كان فيها قافية متكررة
لكن بالتأكيد أن هناك طفولة أو مرحلة طفولة للشعر العربي نحن لا نعرفها
ليش طرّيت هذه الفكرة؟ لأن الأمور لها مقدمات
تاريخية وجغرافية وشأن اجتماعي وعشق للغة أو أفانين القول والبيان
أنتجت إلى أن العربي يكون الشعر هو فنه الأساسي
بينما في أماكن أخرى الفنون الأخرى مثلًا كالنحت
في أوربا أو عند الإغريق أو غيره، أو المسرح عند الإغريق
هذه لها ظروف ثقافية مختلفة، البيئة والموارد لها تأثير
كل المحيط التاريخي والجغرافي والاجتماعي
أكيد أن له أثر فيما يغلب على هذه المنطقة أو تلك
من معارف أو من فنون أو من غيرها
حتى الرياضات تنتشر في أماكن لمثل هذه الأسباب جغرافية وبيئة وطقس
والملابس نفس الشيء، كل شيء أتوقع أنه...
وهل كان عند العرب شيء غير الشعر؟
أدوات التواصل أو التعبير؟
خلينا نقول اللغة لأن الشعر أكيد أنه ليس أول شيء
وأنا ماني مع اللي يبالغوا في أن الشعر هو أهم ما أخترع العرب
صحيح أنه شيء مهم جدًّا لكنه ليس أهم ما اخترع العرب
عندنا كتابة ونثر عربي عظيم جدًّا
عندنا فنون الحكم والأمثال هذه التي لم يلتفت إليها أحد
هذا خط عظيم جدًّا
اهتم الناس، وحقهم الشعر منجز عظيم وأسطوري وخرافي
وممكن نستطيع القول إنه ربما لا يوجد شعر
بهذا التراكم والجودة والامتداد
كما هو عند العرب يمكن في الأمور الأخرى
هذه وجهة نظري الشخصية يمكنها متحيزة أو لا
لكن هذا اللي أنا أشعر فيه
لكن بالغ الناس أو النقاد اللي تلقوا كلمة الشعر ديوان العرب
الديوان هو السجل فقط، وليس هو مفخرة العرب
بمعنى أنه...
لأنه قال عمر بن الخطاب، رضي الله عنه، أو غيره من القدامى أو الأوائل
أن ديوان العرب أصبحوا رقم واحد
صحيح هو في النهاية صار رقم واحد أكيد
لكن معنى الديوان هو الشيء الذي تُجمع فيه الأشياء وتُسجل
وحتى الجملة التي بعدها اللي فيها أنسابهم وأحسابهم
مُدونة في الشعر، والشعر مرتبط بالحياة أكيد
لكن عندنا مُنجز في النثر العربي سواءً في الخطابة
لو تطلع على مثلًا خطابة الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
الأحاديث وما فيها من إعجاز عظيم
والخطباء العرب الأوائل «أكثم بن صيفي» أو «قس بن ساعدة»
أو ذاك الزعيم «هانئ بن مسعود الشيباني» في معركة ذي قار
اللي كانت ضد الفرس، وما جاء بعدها
يا رجل الأمثال اللي نحن نستعملها
وهي تلبي احتياجاتنا العاطفية أو الحياتية أو الشعورية
وما نفكر، كيف نشأت؟
بينما المثل له قصة وحادثة
الحادثة والقصة هذه فيها تاريخ واجتماع وعادات وموروث وإحالات واستعارات
أقصد استعارات معرفية، وليس استعارات بيانية
والأخبار عندنا، يا عبدالرحمن، شيء اسمه الخبر في الأدب العربي
الأخبار اللي تقرأها في قصص العرب أو الخبر أنه جاء رجل وحصل كذا
حتى الدراسات فيه شحيحة جدًّا
مع أن الأخبار هذه خطيرة جدًّا، وكُتب فيها كتب قديمة
«عيون الأخبار» لـ«ابن قتيبة» وغيرهم
فأنا أقصد أن المبالغة في أن الشعر هو المفخرة الأساس للثقافة العربية
هذا رأي مجحف بحق المنجزة العربية
أنت قبل شوي تقول: أن من قديم، وهم يقدمون الشاعر على الخطيب
ولو الآن تجيب أي أحد، وتقدر تسأله عن...
أن تقول: اعطني عشرة شُعراء عرب
يعدد لك إياهم على طول، أي أحد نتكلم
بينما لو تقول له: اعطني خطيبين، ما جابهم
فواضح أن حاضر في ذهن العرب، وواضح أنه اللي وثق تاريخ العرب
فكيف ما تعطيه هذه الأهمية، وأن فعلًا هو أهم ما أنتج العرب؟
أنا قلت لك: أنه من أهم ما أُنجز عبر التاريخ
قلت لك: لا توجد أمة تقريبًا لديها مُنجز شعري مثلما عند العرب
لكنه ليس الوحيد، هناك منجز مهم
ما أحد يقول: أنه الوحيد
أنت تقول: أن ما أحد يعرف خطباء
هذه المشكلة ليس في ديوان النثر العربي مثلًا
أو في المنجز الكتابي العربي
لكن التلقي نفسه، مسألة التلقي، وإبراز هذه الصور
أن سيرورة الشعر لها أسباب كثيرة جدًّا أكيد
الإيقاعية وسهولة الحفظ
لكن الشعر في عصور متأخرة بعد العصر الجاهلي تراجع أمام الكتابة
فيها كلام، طبعًا
لما بنهايات العصر الأموي، وبدايات العصر العباسي
أصبحت الكتابة تنافس الشعر، وربما تتفوق عليه
بل أن إذا كان الشعراء يُقدّرون بالأعطيات وبالجوائز والمنح المالية
أو الإقطاعات أو الخلع كما يسمى من الحُكّام والأمراء
الكتابة كانت توصل إلى الوزارة، وتصبح وزيرًا
معنى وزير ربما رئيس وزراء، ليس فقط حقيبة في المسمى الآن
فقط لأنه كاتب، ويجيد الكتابة، بل بعضهم لأنه حسن الخط فقط
هناك كُتّاب من الدواوين عند السلاطين كانت للكتاب بالدرجة الأولى
وهناك فقط من يُعيّنون ويُعطون الرواتب، لأنه حسن الخط
بينما ذاك حسن الأسلوب
الشاعر؟
لا، الكاتب، في كُتاب شخص...
أسلوبه جيد وفيه واحد خطه جيد
أسلوبه جيد وربما خطه غير جيد فقط هذا لتجويد الخط
يمكن أصلًا وزير آنذاك شيء عادي
الشاعر هو الشيء اللي لا يحصل عليه أحد، لا أحد يصل لهذا المقام
فمقام الشاعر عند العرب أعلى من الوزير، ربما
الشعراء كانوا يمدحون الوزراء ليحصلوا على أُعطياتهم
ما في مشكلة
عندنا وزراء زي «بن زياد» وزي مجموعة والله ما تحضرني للأسف
بس وزراء كبار ومثقفين أساسًا هم
هو المسألة ليست...، الآن ما احنا في إثبات من أفضل
أنا أقول: أنه...، وهذه دعوة حتى للقراء المهتمين
مُنجز مثل مُنجز «أبو حيان التوحيدي» أو «أبو عثمان الجاحظ»
أو «أسامة بن المنقذ» في العصور المتأخرة
كتب الرحلات القديمة لـ«ابن فضلان» و«اليعقوبي» وغيرهم
هذه منتجات أدبية عظيمة من النثر
للأسف أن ما في أحد الآن يتحدث عنها
الآن كم مثلًا بودكاست عندنا؟ ما أحد يتحدث إلا شعر تقريبًا
وأنا ماني متابع، وأنت صحح لي، سمعت أحد؟
لا أنا أفهمك صح بس هم يتكلمون الشعر
لأنه فن أكثر من أن النثر هو معلومات ومعرفة
فممكن تتكلم عن الجاحظ بمئات الحلقات ومئات...
أنا أزعم أن الجاحظ وكتبه وكل الكتب اللي ذكرتها وغيرها من اللي في باب النثر
إنها أكثر مبيعًا وانتشارًا وقراءةً من دواوين الشعر
بس هذيك تؤخذ كفن أكثر من إنها كمعرفة
فهنا معرفة هنا يأخذ كذا كاستئناس
جميل، وكأنك تقول: أنه ترفيه
لا، بس لأنه فيها هذا الإيقاع والفكرة والهجاء
فهي سواليف وهنا علم، أقدر أخليها كذا، هذه أقرب إلى كذا
لأن النثر ما هو فقط نواحي علمية فقط، مثلًا مدونات...
بس الجاحظ كله علم وللا؟
خلينا نبعد أنه علم وللا فن
لأنه أساسًا من معاني الشعر أو كلمة شعر في اللغة العربية العلم
حتى تقول أنت: ألا ليت شعري، ليتني أعلم
فهذه المسألة الإبستمولوجية خلنا منها الآن
خلينا نتكلم عن البيان الجميل
الكتابة الأدبية الرائعة، مو اللي تقدّم فقط معلومة
الكتابة الجمالية اللي فيها حكمة ومسألة نفسية وجانب شعوري
تناقش مثلًا مسألة الخوف من الموت عند «أبو حيان التوحيدي»
أو مسألة كتب «الأمالي»
اللي يجلس إمام أو عالم، ويُملي
والشباب يكتبون، ويخرج في النهاية كتاب «أمالي الزجاجي»
و«أمالي، أبي علي القالي» أو غيره
الجاحظ ألّف رسائل عظيمة
اترك «البيان والتبيين» و«الحيوان» هذه كتب أسفار عظيمة
لكن تعال إلى رسائل الجاحظ
رسالة في «فخر السودان على البيضان» ورسالة في «البخلاء»
هذه عبقرية من أنه...
ترى الفن إذا ما هو مرتبط بالحياة ما يُؤثر
لما يتحدث عن البخلاء
لو كان من ناحية بحث اجتماعي كان أدانهم أو تحدث عن صفاتهم
لكنه جعل منهم أفلام سينمائية
وجعلهم يتكلمون، ويفتخرون ويبررون ويفلسفون، وأصبح البخل قيمة
هل أراد أن يدعو إلى البخل؟
أنت حتى تنهي كتاب الجاحظ ما تدري هو معه وللا ضد
لأنه أراد أن يعرض الحالة
وفيه مفاخرات عقدوها
يا رجل في مناظرات خيالية أُقيمت بين السيف والقلم مثلًا
نسيت والله الكاتب، لكن في العصور القرن الخامس الهجري
بين السيف والقلم مناظرة خيالية، انظر إلى أين وصل؟
أن هذا القلم يفتخر بإنه صاحب العلم
وأن يكتب المعاهدات السلمية ويكتب كذا
وذاك يقول له: أنا من الحديد أنزلني الله، ومش عارف أيش
فاللي أقصده، حتى لا أُفهم خطأً
أنت صح
الشعر فن عظيم جدًّا، وهو مفخرة من مفاخر العرب أكيد
لكن اختزال الثقافة العربية في المسألة الشعرية أو المنجز الشعري
هذا فيه اختزال كبير لمنتج ضخم جدًّا في الثقافة العربية
بس يا أبو شادن ما تتفق أن برضو هذه الكتب إنها أخذت حظها
«رسائل الجاحظ» و«الحيوان» وكلها؟
ما أشوفها ماخذة حظها أبدًا
لو تأخذ أي أحد، تلقى هذه الكتب...
ما أذكر أحد كان يقول، ممكن تلقى ناس تقرأ هذه الكتب
وما أذكر أن مر عليه أحد إلا يمكن «أبو فجر» يقرأ ديوان
فالدواوين لا تُقرأ، عادةً تُكتب وتترك، إلا للمهتمين جدًّا
بينما العامة يهتمون بالمنتج النثري أكثر، تتوقع كذا؟
أنا اللي أشوفه الآن أن أصلًا الاهتمام بالمنجز التراثي قليل أساسًا
الآن الناس تقرأ وغالبًا...
وحتى في فترة غلب علينا، القارئ هو اللي يقرأ روايات
هذا التيك توك
لا، حتى من قبل لأن أساسًا صار عندنا زي ما يسمونه تسونامي الرواية السعودية
من بعد الـ2000 صار عندنا انفجار
وصار عندنا سنويًّا بحدود 150 رواية
فالكتب هذه، حتى ما تقول لي مين يكتب
أنت الحين قلتها قبل شوي، خلني أخذ من لسانك
تقول: عدد لي عشرة خطباء؟ ما أحد يعرف
عدد لي عشر كُتاب؟ ما أحد يعرف، غير الرواية الحديثة
لكن اهتمامنا أساسًا بالشعراء القدامى أو بالمنجز العربي الثقافي القديم أساسًا قليل
ولأن الشعر مادة جميلة، وتلبي احتياج
وتملؤك بالأكسجين أحيانًا، حتى غير المفيد
لكن لأنه فيه إيقاع واتساع معين وتستشهد فيه صار رائج نوعًا ما
لكن النثر لا والله ما أحد يعرف غير الجاحظ، وغير...، بالعكس
محمود درويش مثلًا عنده كتب نثرية من أجمل ما كُتب
مثل كتاب «ذاكرة للنسيان»
وكتاب آخر أهم منه في نظري، والله كتاب عظيم
يمكن نثر محمود درويش مثل الشعراء تقريبًا، كتاب...
لكن اللي اطّلع عليه قليل
أيضًا الكُتاب لو نعدهم
ربما يتفوق عدد الكُتاب النثر العربي القديم على عدد الشعراء
لكن لا أحد يعرفهم
ليست كلها علم ولا نقاش بل بالعكس كتب أدبية
مثل كتاب «البصائر والذخائر» لـ«أبي حيان التوحيدي»
أو «المقابسات» وهو سمر الليالي
اللي كان في المجالس اللي يسهرون فيها
ويكتب المقابسة الليلة الأولى والثانية
بل حتى «ألف ليلة وليلة» الناس ما تعرف أصلًا ما سبب كتابته
أيش قصة «ألف ليلة وليلة»؟
يعرفون أن «شهرزاد» تحكي لـ«شهريار»
وبعد 1000 سنة جاءت له بثلاثة أبناء وعفى عنها
بس ليش أساسًا يبغى يقتلها؟
ليش كان «شهريار» يبغى يقتل «شهرزاد»؟
ما أحد يعرف أساسًا القصة، كيف جاءت؟
وهي قصة متخيلة، وليست حقيقية
فأنا أقصد مع أنه طلعت منها منتجات رائعة في أفلام كرتون أو في أشياء
لكن أنا ما زلت أدعو
وهذه دعوة أنا ما أنتقد بقدر ما أدعو إلى النظر في الكتابة العربية القديمة
وأن فيها كنوز جمالية ومعرفية واجتماعية وثقافية كبيرة جدًّا
أتمنى أن يصير في اطّلاع عليها واهتمام فيها
ونسمع كم بودكاست عن النثر العربي
إن شاء الله، الكثير...
الحين بأخذ شيء من لسانك بس أني بسأل عنه
أنت قبل شوي تقول: أن الشعر العربي
كانت ذروته في الشعر الجاهلي صحيح؟
صحيح
أيش رأيك في اللي يقوله طه حسين: بأن أصلًا ما كان فيه شعر جاهلي؟
طه حسين أساسًا يقول برضو مقولة ثانية
يقول: لا نجد شعر أمة من الأمم يعبر عن حياة هذه الأمة وكل ثقافتها وتفاصيلها
كما فعل الشعر العربي
طه حسين، وأنا أتمنى ما ندخل في هذا الموضوع أساسًا
تبغانا نمشي؟
إيه
الموضوع إشكالي، بس طه حسين كان في فترة من فترات
تبع المنهج التشكيكي «مرقليوث» والجماعة
بالعكس طه حسين من أهم من تحدث عن الشعر العربي
في كتاب «حديث الشعر والنثر» تكلم كلام مرة مهم
لكن خلينا نعدي النقطة هذه
نعدّيها، بس القصد فهو كتب فيما بعد
إذا هو يبغى يمشي مع هذه المروية
أنها كُتبت فيما بعد على أنها شعر جاهلي
فمعناته أن كان فيه عصر ذهبي في الشعر العربي ما بعد
مثلًا في الدولة الأموية وللا في العباسية وللا؟
الشعر العربي الحقيقي هو الشعر ما قبل الإسلام
لأنه ما بعد ذلك اختُطف لأيديولوجيات
ولمدائح براغماتية نفعية تخدم أغراض الشعراء المتكسبين
فأنا أفضل الشعر الجاهلي لأنه كان ممكن نقول: خالص، شعر
مفهوم الشعر أساسًا، وحتى مفهوم الشعر الرائج
قضى على فكرة الشعر وجوهره
«حسان ابن ثابت» لما جاء ابنه لما قرصته حشرة
وقال له: لقد قرصني شيء ما، فقال له: كيف شكله؟
فوصف الألوان بأنها مثل الثوب اليماني الأحمر والأصفر
«كأنه مُلتفُُ في بردي حبرة»
قال: ابن الشعر والله
لا وزن ولا قافية ولا شيء
الشعر مفهومه أساسًا أختطف لنواحي الشكل
ولذلك كل صراعاتنا
يقول لك: قصيرة النثر اسمها خطأ، وليست شعر لأنها خالية من الوزن
والله يسامح «ابن رشيق القيرواني»
اللي حط تعريف الشعر أنه كلامُُ موزونُُ مقفًا بقصد
حقيقة إنه هذا التعريف للشعر قضى على الشعر
لأنه اختزله في الإيقاع والوزن والقافية والقصدية
حط القصدية حتى يخرج منه الحديث الشريف والقرآن الكريم
لكن الجاحظ ماذا يعرف الشعر؟
يقول: الشعر صناعة وفي رواية صياغة
الشعر صناعة ونسيجُُ وضربُُ من التصوير، أو هكذا يقول
هذا التعريف الحقيقي
عندما تحيك الجمال، وتخرج فكرة أو شعور أو تجربة أيًّا كانت في إطار جمالي
هذا هو الشعر
كان نثر أو خياطة أو نقش أو أغنية، هذا هو الشعر
ولذلك الآن لما يُقال: السينما الشعرية أو... بهذا المفهوم
صوت المطر لما «تاركوفسكي» في فلم نسيت اسمه
يفسح لصوت المطر فقط أن يتحدث
لحظة الصمت اللي حطها «كريستوفر نولان» في لحظة التفجير
في فلم أوبنهايمر، هذا الشعر
لأنه قدم لك الحالة نقلك أو أدخلك فيها
يا إما نقلها إليك حتى احتلتك أو أخذك، وقذفك فيها، هذا هو الشعر
فالشعر الجاهلي يا عزيزي شعر مرتبط بالإنسان
ومرتبط بالمكان، ومرتبط بالقيم وبالحوادث
وهو شعر فطري
العرب ما كانت متطلعة على الفلسفة اليونانية
أو قرأت أدب مترجم أو فكر مترجم أو طب
معارفهم في هذا الاتجاه قليلة
معارفهم في قصص الأثر، ويعرفون البلدان المجاورة الأجنبية
لذلك عندما نتحدث عن الشعر العربي يجب أن نخرج الشعر ما قبل الإسلام
في كفة
نعم، لأن فيما بعد في العصر الأموي أو في عصر صدر الإسلام
كما قال الرواة والنقاد القدامى: أنه ضعف ولان
كما يقول ذلك الناقد: أن الشعر بابه شر فإذا دخل في الخير ضعف
فلذلك الشعر في صدر الإسلام صار أقل، وانشغل أصلًا كثير
هذا يرجعنا لكلام اللي قلناه من شوي: أنه متأثر بالظروف المحيطة
الناس تتعلم القرآن والناس تجاهد وتتعلم الدين الجديد
فانشغلت عن الشعر
حتى «لبيد بن ربيعة» وهو شاعر من شعراء المعلقات
يقال: أنه ما قال إلا بيت واحد، لما أسلم
وهو بيت فيه قيمة دينية، وخالي تمامًا من الشعر
أَلا كُلُّ شَيءٍ ما خَلا اللَهَ باطِلُ
وكُلُّ نَعيمٍ لا مَحالَةَ زائِلُ
كلام خالي من ربما الناحية الجمالية
هذا يدلك على أنهم انشغلوا بما هو أهم
ربما في حياتهم أو في دينهم أو في الجهاد والفتوحات
في العصر الأموي أخذ يُلبي الاحتياجات السياسية والعصبية القبلية
أو ما بين الأمويين والعباسيين والعلويين والزبيريين والشيعة
وكلهم لهم شعراؤهم
وأصبح عبارة عن بيانات سياسية
أو سب وشتم وقذف ما بين «جرير» و«الفرزدق» و«الأخطل»
هؤلاء...، وهو منجز جميل لغويًّا وقبليًّا وفي التاريخ مهم
لكنه زي ما أقول لك: الشعر في العصر الأموي اختطف
في العصر العباسي هناك شعراء كبار «أبو تَمّام» و«البحتري»
ثم «العبقري» و«أبو الطيب المتنبي»
إضافة إلى «بشار» والعظيم «أبو العلاء المعري»
ومجموعة كبار من الشعراء، وأيضًا في كُتاب كبار
الدولة الإسلامية استقرت
وصار في حضارة معينة، وصار في وفر وموارد اقتصادية
وصار في عمارة ومعارف أجنبية كبيرة ترجمات وبيت الحكمة
بدأ هنا مد ثقافي كبير من ضمنه الشعر
لكن الشعر العربي الجاهلي هو الشعر الجميل جدًّا
اللي يحتاج إلى قراءة مختلفة في وجهة نظري
لم يحظى بها بشكل شائع وعام إلى الآن اللي هي القراءة الحضارية
أيش تقصد؟
القراءة الحضارية يا عزيزي أن المكوّن الحضاري في الشعر
هذا المنتج الفني الثقافي فيه غزل، حسنًا جميل
وإن كان الغزل هذا أخذ أكبر من حجمه
الغزل في القصيد العربي في المطالع فقط أو في أجزاء لا توجد تقريبًا
لا توجد قصيدة غزلية من بدايتها إلى نهايتها في ديوان الشعر العربي القديم
الجاهلي تحديدًا
بل كان يأتي في ظل ما يسمى بعمود الشعر
اللي هو يتكلم عن الأطلال، ويتكلم عن الراحلة
ثم يتكلم عن سواءً كانت «سعاد» أو «دعد» أو «هند»
ثم ينتقل إلى الغرض الذي يريده سواءً كان مدح «النعمان بن المنذر»
أو هجاء قبيلة أخرى أو فخر بقبيلته أو رثاء أو غيره
تقليد شعري يأتي من خلاله الغزل
فاللي أقوله: أنه فيه جوانب في الغزل
وفيه جوانب مثلًا قبيلة وتاريخ ووقائع وفخر
لكن فيه جوانب حضارية كثيرة جدًّا
إذا رجعنا لمفهوم الحضارة مثلًا خلنا نأخذ «ويل ديورانت»
في «قصة الحضارة»
يُعرّف الحضارة: أنها تقوم على عوامل عدة إذا توافرت في حقبة زمنية أو في دولة
صار عندها حضارة
اللي هي الموارد الاقتصادية أولًا والأنظمة السياسية والتقاليد الأخلاقية ربما
أو الأعراف والتقاليد عمومًا
والأمر الرابع: الإسهام الثقافي والمعرفي أو الفني
هنا تصير في حضارة
تعال نتلمس هذه الأشياء في الشعر العربي نجدها كلها موجودة وبقوة
الجاهلي تقصد؟
الجاهلي، هم يفرقون بين الشعر والقصيد
القصيد هو...
ولذلك يقولون: أن المهلهل «الزير»
هو أول من قصّد القصائد، وأكثر من قول الشعر
حتى الشعراء في الجاهلية يتفاوتون
ولما جاء «ابن سلام الجمحي» وحط طبقات
وحط ما يسميهم بالفحول، هؤلاء تجد لهم شعر طويل
بل أن المعلقات من ميزاتها أنها طويلة
وأسماء اسمها الأساسي «القصائد السبعة الطوال» الطول علامة
عنصر مهم
إي، أن الشاعر يستطيع أن يُفتّق من الأبيات، وينتقل بين المشاعر
مثلًا معلقة امرؤ القيس فيها حرب وغزل وعبث ومجون وثأر وفخر
«معلقة طرفة» 103 أبيات مثلًا
فالقصيد هو الشعر المقصد أي المقسم إلى بيتين، صدر وعجز وقافية
فالمحور أو القراءة الحضارية للشعر أو القصيد العربي القديم مهمة جدًّا
تجد فيها التقاليد والعادات، تجد فيه حتى يا رجل العلاقة مع الحيوان
شيء راقي جدًّا، يرثي الناقة ويتغزل فيها
الخيل، الفَرَس، وكيف أن عنترة وهو في المعركة يتكلم مع الخيل
ترك كل شيء، وتكلم مع اثنين مع...
ولقد ذكرتك والرماح نواهل منّي
وبيض الهند تقطر من دمي
فودتت تقبيل السيوف
لأنها لمعت كبارق ثغرك المتبسم
لمعة السيوف ذكرته بأسنان الحبيبة
ومع كثرة الكر والهجوم «حتى تسربل بالدم» اللي هو حصانه
يقول: «فازور» التفت إليه الحصان، انكمش
فازور من وقع القنا بلبانه
وشكا إلي بعبرةٍ وتحمحم
لو كان يدري ما المحاورة اشتكى
ولكان لو علم الكلام مكلمي
العلاقة بالحيوان ووصف الأرض
والأشياء المادية سواءً الياقوت أو الجوهر أو...
غير العادات والتقاليد الراسخة
يقول: «من معشر سنّت لهم آباؤهم» في سُنن متبعة
فأقصد القراءة الحضارية للشعر القديم تخرجنا ربما وتطلعنا على جوانب نفعية
جوانب عليها العمل ونستلهمها
ليس فقط أن للأنساب وللحروب وللوقائع وللغزل وللاستشهاد
قيمة الشعر العربي أهم من ذلك بكثير فقط إذا قُرئت قراءة ثقافية وحضارية
بعيدًا عن القراءات سواءً المناهج الأدبية الكثيرة
اللي هي الشكلانية والبنيوية والسيميائية
هذه التي لا تمس الحياة أو ينتفع منها الإنسان
واشتكى منها حتى «تودوروف» لما كتب كتابه الشهير
«الأدب في خطر»
الأدب في خطر بسبب أنه أصبحت هذه المناهج
اللي تدرس الأدب أهم من الأدب نفسه فقط
وموجود هذا في رسائلنا الجامعية وكتبنا الأكاديمية
أنه دراسة سيميائية وبنيوية وأسلوبية وإحصائية
جميلة ومهمة ومتخصصة
لكن هناك قراءة ثقافية نقرأ فيها الإنسان والأبعاد الأخلاقية والتقاليد
ونبني عليها التراكم
اللي نبغاه ينغرس في الإنسان العربي والفرد العربي في هذا اليوم
وهذا ينطبق على الجاهلي وصدر الإسلام والأموي والعباسي
وللا فقط الجاهلي؟
وهذا موجود في هذه الدراسات والأبحاث
وللا هو ناقص من كل العصور؟
لا، في ناس درسوه، أنا بقول لك: أنه غير موجود، لكنه قليل جدًّا
قليل، إي فاهمك
القراءة ينبغي أن تُقرأ في الإرث الثقافي كله
حتى الإرث الشعري الشعبي
هل في غزارة لعصر عن عصر وللا هو قليل في كل العصر؟
لا، هو قليل
ربما يمكن العصر العباسي والأندلسي حظيا بدراسة حضارية أكثر
لأن أساسًا كانت الحضارة شيء طاغي، لا تستطيع أن تتجاهله
ما تستطيع أن لا تدرسه، ما تقدر
سواءً في العصور العباسية أو الأندلس
لكن فيه من يظن أنه قبل العصر الجاهلي ما كان فيه حضارة أساسًا
فالمنهج الحضاري أو الدراسة الحضارية للمنجز الثقافي
يمكن ما تلاقي أشياء تلبيها
لكن بالعكس حسب المفهوم وحسب الوعي أساسًا بهذه الأشياء
استوقفتني فكرة أن الشعر يزدهر في فترة الرخاء والاستقرار للدولة
بينما يجي برضو في بالي أن الشعر كان يستخدم كسلاح
سواءً في العصر الجاهلي، وما بعده حتى
وأنت قلتها: يُعتبر كأنه بيان، وفيه هجاء ومديح
وفيه أنه يرفع من همته، ويشحذ الهمم للحروب وغيرها
فليش يخفت الشعر في هذه الفترات؟
وليش يزدهر في فترات الرخاء فقط؟
الشعر، يمكن أنا بكلامي ما وصل بالشكل اللي أنا أقصده
أنا أقصد أنه في العصر العباسي صار في استقرار سياسي
وصار في وظائف ووفر اقتصادي وفي حياة
وفي شرطة ودواوين وأشياء موجودة
فالمثقف تفرّغ للإنتاج الثقافي
بينما ممكن يكون الغزارة تنوع، وكثرة عدد الشعراء أو الأدباء أو المثقفين
والورّاقين ونسخ الكتب والتأليف، وحركة التدوين ازدهرت
بينما ليست فقط دلالة على جودة الشعر
ربما يكون هناك كثرة وانتشار
لكن الجودة ليست مرهونة أو مرتبطة بالاستقرار
بالعكس يمكن...
مثلًا في أحد الحروب الصليبية لم يبقى أحد لم يكتب الشعر
أيام أزمة الخليج، كل المواطنين السعوديين تقريبًا تحولوا إلى شعراء
فالشعر هو موجود في الدم العربي تقريبًا، هناك أحوال تستفزه ليخرج
ربما يخرج نظم خالي من الجمال، وربما يخرج جيد
فاللي أنا أقصده من كلامي أن الانتشار والكثرة في عصور الاستقرار ربما تجعل...
حتى الفن والأشياء كلها تزدهر
لأن إذا في حرب أو دمار أو غارات متبادلة
حتى الأشياء الفنية أو المنتج الفني يتأثر أكيد
بس برضو أنت في البداية كنت تقول: أن الشعر مو بشيء هامشي أو رفاهية
هو أساس
طبعًا الشعر ما هو بشيء...، ولذلك يلجأ إليه الإنسان في لحظات الأزمات
مثلًا في الحروب
حتى يمكن ما شهد التاريخ العربي عدد شعراء
كما في عصر الحروب الصليبية، نعم كلهم
لأنه أصبح يعبر عن أزمة الإنسان ووصف الدمار ووصف القتل
أو استنهاض الهمم أو التحميس أو هجاء الأعداء، وما إلى ذلك
وهذه استمرت 200 سنة، ما هي فترة بسيطة
في الفترة العباسية
كانت فترة دخل كثير من غير العرب في المجتمع العربي، وأصبحوا عربًا
هل أثر دخول الفرس وغيرهم على تلقي أو كتابة الشعر؟
الأمر أكبر من الشعر، يا عبدالرحمن
الدخول...، هذا يمكن يودينا إلى موضوع دخول ثقافات أخرى وثقافة الآخر
الأعراق واللغات والأديان الأخرى
دخولها في الحياة والثقافة العربية أو الإسلامية
هذا عصر إشكالي، لكن الإشكال بدأ قبل ذلك مع...
علاقة العربي بالآخر علاقة قديمة جدًّا
كان عندنا على ساحة الصراع الحضاري أو السيطرة على العالم
ما كان العرب موجودين إلى 2000 سنة تقريبًا
كان في الفرس أو فارس وفي بيزنطة اللي هي جهة تركيا والأماكن هذه
هذه كان الفرس والروم
والعرب عندهم المناذرة والغساسنة كل واحدة تحت حماية
وهم عرب طبعًا
ولكنهم يتبعون بشكل أو بآخر لهم حكم محلي
لكنهم تبع لهذه الإمبراطوريتين اللي أساسًا كانت دائمًا في صراع
العرب في ذيك الفترة قبل الإسلام
كانوا حروب يميلون يمين ويسار
وفي قصص كثيرة مع «عمرو بن هند» ومع الغساسنة والمناذرة
من قبائل عربية والشعر سطّر هذا والأخبار، وأيام العرب في هذا
مع مجيء الإسلام عمل نقلة غير طبيعية ونقلة كاملة
بنزول الوحي، ووجود النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم، والدين الجديد
هذا الدين العظيم اللي هو كله تسامح
ووكله احترام للاختلاف ولا إكراه في الدين
بدأ الآن العنصر العربي اللي هو الحامل لراية الإسلام
يظهر على ساحة الإمبراطوريات العالمية
وفي فترة قياسية طبّق الأرض، حكم المسلمون مساحة شاسعة
ما يهمني في هذا السرد التاريخ
اللي يهمني أن كيف تعامل مع الناس الآخرين من أمم أخرى
بثقافتهم وبأديانهم؟
الاختلاف هو يمكن على قيمتين أو مكونين
مكون إثني اللي هو عرقي
اللي هو جنس عرب وفرس وأحباش وترك وصين وهند وأفارقة
والمكون الآخر اللي هو الديني
مسلم ومسيحي ويهودي يمكن هذه الديانات اللي كانت...
الإسلام كان في عصر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم واضح جدًّا
وفي القرآن والسنة النبوية التسامح
إما يدخل في الإسلام أو معابدهم وأشياءهم لا تُمس
الإشكال صار بعد وفاة النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم، وبداية أبو بكر وعمر
ثم في عهد عثمان بدأت أصلًا الانقسام الداخلي
وبدأ الأمويين يظهرون على الساحة، ومن هنا بدأت...
المؤرخون يقولون: أن في عصر «بني أمية» رجع العرق العربي إلى الساحة
وهو المسيطر، ولم يعد الوحي هو المسيطر
فكان العرب مارسوا قسوة على غير العرب
وفي حوادث في التاريخ تدل على هذا
ولذلك استعان العباسيون في ثورتهم على الأمويين بعرق آخر اللي هو فارس
«أبو مسلم الخراساني» و«أبو سلمة الخلال» ومجموعة، وقرّبوهم
وهنا فعلًا، زي ما تفضلت، طغت الثقافة الفارسية، ودخل...
إذا كنا نتحدث عن الشعر، ظهر عندنا ناس اسمهم المولّدون
المولدون اللي هم غير العرب اللي تعلموا اللغة العربية
زي «بشار بربورد» مثلًا
«بشار» مثلًا ما يدخل...، مختلفين العلماء أهل النحو واللغة
هل يُستشهد بشعره أم لا؟ تخيل «بشار»
لكنه كان يهجوهم، وغصب عنهم يحطوا له أبيات في الـ...
هجى الأخ «فشفة» وهجى «سيبويه»
أو أنه ما هجاه لكن اتقاء لشره استشهد بواحد من أبياته
فالفكرة أن في...
زي ما قلت لك قبل شوي
أن أي حضارة عظيمة يجب أن تستفيد من التنوع
أو لن تكون عظيمة حتى توظّف هذا التنوع في منجزها الكلي
الدولة العباسية، وأنا لا أمدح حقبة عن حقبة
كل حقبة وكل دولة لها ما لها وعليها ما عليها، والجميع يعرف ذلك
لكن التنوع والثراء بدأ بشكل كبير في العصر العباسي
ودخلت الثقافة الفارسية والهندية، وبدأت تترجم
بل أن وصل التأثير أو كان سبب كبير من أسباب التأثير
أن أساسًا الخلفاء معظم أمهاتهم غير عربيات
وهذا أدى إلى الاستعانة بالفرس في فترة ثم نكبتهم
ثم الاستعانة بالتُرك ثم كذا وكذا
أنا نسيت السؤال
علاقتها وبأثرها على التلقي أو كتابة شعر
الشعر استفاد أكيد من هذه المقومات كلها
لأنه أساسًا كل ثقافة لها منزع أو لها زاوية نظر للأشياء
كل ثقافة لها حكمتها وفلسفاتها وطبائعها، وزاويا نظرها للأشياء
فالمدونة الشعرية العربية استفادت من هذا استفادة كبيرة جدًّا
وظهر هذا في أشعار «أبي تمام»
الجانب الفلسفي اللي فيه أو جانب الحكمة
أو حتى جانب الغموض اللي عند «أبي تمام»
وهذا ما كان قبل عصر «أبو تمام»
ثورة «أبي نواس» الشهيرة على «المقدمة الطلالية»
اللي لازم نمر على الأطلال واللي يقول...
حتى يسخر يقول: قُل لِمَن يَبكي عَلى رَسمٍ دَرَس واقِفًا
ما ضَرَّ لَو كانَ جَلَس؟
يعني اقعد يا أخي لا توقف، يتريق
أو يقول: عاج الشقي...
سمي الشاعر العربي القديم أو اللي ما زال يقلد الشعراء العرب
يقول: عاج الشقي على رسم يُسائله
وعجت أسأل عن خمارة البلد
ويقولون: أنه وقع بدل المقدمة الطلالية استبدلها بمقدمة خمرية
والمفروض أنه يخرج من هذا كله، ويدخل في الغرض مباشرة
فالشعر، أكيد المدونة الشعرية العربية استفادت من هذه كلها
«أبو العلاء المعري» وحديثه عن فلسفة...
حتى في أغراض شعرية دخلت في الشعر العربي ما كانت موجودة
مثلًا وصف الطبيعة ما كان...
كغرض قار في وصف الطبيعة، وصف جبل ووصف نهر ووصف قصر ووصف البركة
«البُحتري» له قصيدة عظيمة في وصف البركة
يقول: تنصب فيها...
أنه كان بشكل جمالي كذا مو بس مجرد بركة
يقول: تنصبُّ فيها وفودُ الماءِ مُعجلةً
كالخيلِ خارجةً من حبلِ مُجريْها
إذا النُّجومُ تراءتْ في جوانِبِها ليلًا
حسبْتَ سماءً رُكِّبتْ فيها
فهذا غرض كامل استجد
وهذا نرجع لمسألة الاستقرار والرفاة والموارد الاقتصادية
في أغراض جديدة حُقِنت بأفكار جديدة
يعني الرثاء إلى العصر العباسي كان مجرد أنه تعداد محاسن الميت
وَإِنَّ صَخرًا لَوالِينا وَسَيِّدُنا
وَإِنَّ صَخرًا إِذا نَشتو لَنَحّار
في العصر العباسي لا أصبح في حديث عن ما يسمى بمسألة الموت والحياة
وهذه الحوارية بين «أبو العلاء المعري»
حتى له قصيدة اللي هي «غَيْرُ مُجْدٍ فِي مِلَّتِي وَاعْتِقَادِي
نَوْحُ بَاكٍ وَلَا تَرَنُّمُ شَادِ»
يصف القبر يقول: «رُبَّ لَحْدٍ قَدْ صَارَ لَحْدًا مِرَارًا...»
يعني دُفنوا فيه أكثر من شخص
«ضَاحِكٍ مِنْ تَزَاحُمِ الْأَضْدَادِ» غني وفقير ولص وشريف
ويقول: صاحِ مَا أَظُنُّ أَدِيمَ الْـأَرْضِ...
قبلها يقول: خَفِّفِ الْوَطْءَ...
يعني إذا جيت تمشي امشي بشويش
فأنت تراك قاعد تدعس على آباءك وأجدادك
«خَفِّفِ الْوَطْءَ مَا أَظُنُّ أَدِيمَ الأرض إِلَّا مِنْ هَذِهِ الْأَجْسَادِ
صَاحِ هَذِهْ قُبُورُنَا تَمْلَأُ الرُّحْــبَ
فَأَيْنَ الْقُبُورُ مِنْ عَهْدِ عَادِ؟
رُبَّ لَحْدٍ قَدْ صَارَ لَحْدًا مِرَارًا» إلى آخره
فالإجابة على سؤالك، أن فعلًا المدونة الشعرية العربية استفادت من هذا
ولكن الثقافة العربية ظهر فيها أشياء أخرى، ليس فقط في الشعر
الحركة الشعوبية، وتفضيل غير العرب على العرب، والطعن في العرب
حركة الرد من «ابن قتيبة» والجاحظ وأدباء العرب في تلك الفترة
في الرد على الشعوبيين، ومثالب العرب
وهذا يخلينا يمكن نتحدث عن مسألة أن الآخر في الثقافة العربية، والاختلاف
وإلى أي درجة كانت الثقافة العربية متسامحة
وإلى أي درجة كانت عنصرية أو إقصائية؟
أنا ودي أقفل كم ملف في زمان، إذا تسمح لي؟
مثل؟
ليش الشعراء كان عندهم مشكلة أو يستعيبون الكتابة؟
والله يا أخي هذا شيء عجيب
الإنسان اللي يظن أن الحياة صارت زي كذا وهي كذا الحياة
لا الحياة مو كذا، في مفاهيم مختلفة تمامًا
تخيل أن الكتابة في مرحلة من المراحل كانت عيب لدى المثقف، وشيء عجيب
القراءة والكتابة عيب
ولذلك بنواميس تلك الحقبة
كان الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لا يقرأ ولا يكتب
وكانت هذه فضيلة من فضائله
لأنه يقول لك: لو كان قارئًا أو كاتبًا
«وَقَالُوا أَسَاطِيرُ الْأَوَّلِينَ اكْتَتَبَهَا فَهِيَ تُمْلَىٰ عَلَيْهِ بُكْرَةً وَأَصِيلًا»
والشعراء لم يكونوا يكتبوا، ولا يقرؤون، لنفس الفكرة
القراءة عند العربي يُقدّر معارفه الفطرية اللي اكتسبها من بيئته
إضافة إلى أن ما هي متوافرة هذه الأشياء القراءة والكتابة
مع أنه في مكتبة كانت عند «النعمان بن المنذر»
في مكتبة موجودة، وفيها بعض المخطوطات والكتب
والكتابة كانت تستخدم أو تستعمل لأغراض وظيفية
معاهدات وأشياء معينة
وحتى القرآن الكريم تحدث عنها «إِذَا تَدَايَنْتُمْ بِدَيْنٍ إِلَى أَجَلٍ مُسَمًّى فَاكْتُبُوهُ»
دليل على إنه ما طلب منهم شيء إعجازي بالنسبة لهم
إنما أشار أو أكد على ممارسة موجودة لممارسة الكتابة
هل الكتابة عيب أو تشريف أو ميزة أو صفة سلبية؟
ولماذا كتبت المعلّقات؟
كتبت لـ...
طبعًا إذا صرفنا النظر هل هي كتبت أو علقت أو ما علقت
هل اسمها المعلقات أساسًا؟
كيف هي سبع، وكيف هي عشر عند الناس
عند «النحاس» و«التبريزي»؟
كيف أنه نختلف...؟
مثلًا عندك «النابغة» في قصيدتين له
ناس يأخذوا هذه، وناس يأخذوا هذه
وفي ناس يطلعوا شعراء تمامًا من اللي...
فبصرف النظر، القراءة والكتابة عند العرب القدامى لم تكن سمعتها جيدة
بل أن الشاعر الذي يقرأ أو يكتب كان يُخفي ذلك إلى العصر الأموي
أيش اللي تغير؟
هذا التراكم الحضاري المعرفي صارت القراءة والكتابة أمر ضروري لتعيش
اتجه العصر العباسي...
أساسًا الكتابة ما بدأت إلا بعد 130 سنة تقريبًا
الكتابة الحقيقية كشيء موجود وممارسة معتبرة في نهاية العصر الأموي
والعصر الأموي انتهى في 132
ما ظهر عندنا كاتب سمّوه كاتب
إلا «سالم مولاه هشام بن عبدالملك» من أوائل من كتبوا
وكانت كتابة وظيفية فقط رسائل ومعاهدات
وكتابات الرسول عليه السلام إلى بعض...
أو من السلاطين فيما بعد
«ذُو الرُّمَّة» كان يقرأ يجيد القراءة والكتابة
فكان هناك أحد الذين يجمعون الشعر يُملي عليه «ذُو الرُّمَّة»
اسمه «غيلان بن عقبة»
ويُملي عليه الشعر فأخطأ...
كتب بعض ما أملاه خطأً، أخطأ في حرف أو في كلمة
فقال له: اصلح هذه
فتعجب الرجل ونظر إليه نظرة عجيبة، فقال له: اكتم عني
لأنه لو عرف الرواة أنه قارئ وكاتب لما رووا شعره بعد ذلك
لأنه سيصبح أن لغته غير سليمة
يعني «أبو عمرو بن العلاء» و«المفضل الضبي» والأصمعي
ما كانوا يروون شعر، حي الله شاعر أبدًا
بل أنه عندهم تفريق اللي عايش في المدينة أو القرية
أو عايش في الصحراء في البادية
أيضًا اللي عايش في منطقة قريب من أمة أخرى
قريب من ديار فارس أو الروم مثلًا أو الشام
هذا عربيته ما هي مضمونة
يقول لك: إنه يُستشهد بشعر الشعراء في البادية إلى مثلًا سنة 200 وكذا
بينما نتوقف عند أهل الحضر إلى مثلًا موضوع...
وهذا يخلينا نثق أكثر
وشكرًا لهم ولهذيك الجهود العظيمة كلها
أنه أكدوا على هذا التنزيه
يعني عاملوا اللغة معاملة الوحي، وهذا يشكر لهم، وإيمان منهم
كما يكتب الحديث الشريف، وكما كُتِب القرآن، ولله المثل الأعلى
دوّنت اللغة ودوّنت الأشعار لأن هذا مكمل للوحي أو النصوص الدينية
وهي كلها ضمن الأشياء اللي تكوّن الثقافة العربية والإسلامية بشكل عام
والتدوين حضر في العصر العباسي؟
عصر التدوين يبدأ في منتصف القرن الثاني الهجري
فعلًا من نهاية الدولة الأموية، وانفجر في العصر العباسي
انفجر، وبدأت دكاكين الورّاقيين، ونسخ الكتب
ومعظم المخطوطات اللي وصلتنا اليوم هي من منتجات العصر العباسي
مع أنه فقدنا شيء كثير جدًّا في الحروب، وفي حريق الإسكندرية
في غزو التتار، وحريق مكتبات بغداد أو إحراقها
إضافة للي نُهب أو سُلهب
وكذلك الترجمة كانت في عصر الدولة العباسية؟
نعم
كيف أثرت الترجمة على الثقافة والشعر العربي، وللا ما كان لها حضور؟
لا بالعكس بل أنه حتى حضر بشكل مباشر وغير مباشر
الشكل غير المباشر أنه فيه زوايا النظر، وتعداد أساليب الكتابة
في التشبيهات والاستعارات
زي ما قلنا يا عبدالرحمن في البداية
أن الشعر لا ينزل من لا مكان هو من المدخلات
اللي في ذهنية الإنسان وفي روحه ووعيه من عمارة وأرضه
وحتى من طعامه ولباسه وعاداته وتقاليده وموسيقى ومعارف
هذه كلها تُشّكل طريقة أو مأخذ أدبي
كيف يكتب الجملة، وكيف يصوغ العبارة، وكيف يُشبّه؟
ولذلك دائمًا هناك أشياء جديدة
موجودة في أساليب القول الشعري والأدبي بشكل عام
كانت أثر من آثار معرفة ثقافات الأمم الأخرى
الأثر المباشر وجود هذه المعارف
يعني الفلسفات أن دخلت بشكل مباشر
أسماء كتب «إقليدس» و«جالينوس» و«أرسطو طاليس»
موجودة سواءً في الأبيات الشعرية عند المتنبي أو عند غيره
يَموتُ راعي الضَأنِ في جَهلِهِ
مَوتَةَ جالينوسَ في طِبِّهِ
واضحة، وأيضًا تأثره مثلًا بالمتنبي
لِكُلِّ اِمرِئٍ مِن دَهرِهِ ما تَعَوَّدا
وَعادَةُ سَيفِ الدَولَةِ...
هذه موجودة في كلمة أو مأخوذة من أظن «أفلاطون»
أن الإنسان إنما هو مجموعة عادات
فواضح الأثر كان إيجابي جدًّا
نقل...، بل مؤخرًا أو في النتيجة النهائية
أنه كانت الحضارة العربية هي الوسيط الأمثل
لنقل الحضارات الإغريقية والرومانية إلى الزمن هذا
حيث جاؤوا أوربا، واهتموا بالحضارة العربية لأن فيها كنوز عرفوها
ربما قبلنا عرفوها، للأسف، واستفادوا منها
سواءً في الأندلس أو مع الحروب الصليبية لما أخذوا كثير من الأشياء العربية
أو مع العلاقات التجارية والاقتصادية والرحلات
فكان دور الحضارة العربية ليس فقط دور الوسيط
قلت لك: الوسيط الأمثل، وأنا كنت حريص على كلمة الأمثل
لأنه ما كانوا فقط جسر، قدموا إضافات عظيمة
قدموا إضافات في الرياضيات والفلك والطب والفيزياء
وفي مخترعات كثيرة جدًّا في الفلك
فكانوا وسيط فعلًا حضاري
وليس مجرد قناة عبرت منها الحضارة أو المعرفة، والتقطتها أوربا
وهذا موجود ما يحتاج أن نحن نثبته أو ندافع عنه
لأن أي شخص يتبعه وموجود في الكتب الحقيقية المنصفة
زي قصة الحضارة وغيرها، موجودة
طيب وعلى مر التاريخ سواءً الكُتاب وللا الشعراء
أيش كان الدافع لهم إنهم يكتبون؟
هل كانت الفلوس والشهرة وللا...؟
تقصد في الثقافة العربية؟
يا أخي كل إنسان يتجه لا بد أن يعبر عن نفسه بشكل من الأشكال
هذا يرجعنا يمكن لفلسفة الفن أو الأدب أو الإبداع نفسه
الخلق أساسًا لماذا؟ لأنه احتياج ببساطة
ولأن الفن والأدب ملاذ
حياة ربما تكون موازية
أنت عشت تجربة في الحياة لا تستطيع أن تغيرها
تجربة صارت موجودة وعشتها
لكنك في الكتابة والسينما والموسيقى
تستطيع أن تعيد خلقها من جديد كما تشاء، من وجهة نظرك
إما تعمقها أو تسخفها أو تأخذها إلى أي اتجاه تريد
عبر اللغة واللون والموسيقى والكاميرا، وعبر أي تقنية فنية موجودة
فما ودي أقول: أن هي صفة من صفات الخلق، الكتابة نفسها
فأي إنسان يصح له أن يخلق عالم ويزهد فيه
بالعكس أنا أحس أنه الدافع ذاتي
والمدخلات من ثقافة ومن حياة كاملة، التشجيع مهم
المأمون لما يجعل وزن الكتاب المترجم ذهبًا
والخلفاء لما يعطون الشعراء الأعطيات
أكيد أن هذا ربما هدفها في الشعراء والمديح غير حضاري أو غير ثقافي
لكن النتيجة صارت ثقافية في الأخير
صحيح
وهذا الشيء جميل
بس لما تتذكر مثلًا في عندك نجيب محفوظ، كان يعاني من أزمة الإهمال
كان يقول: أكتب ولا ألقى صدى اللي أكتبه
فواضح فيه أن الإهمال، وعدم حضوره بين الناس
كان واضح أنه مهم بالنسبة له
ما كانت الكتابة لدافع الكتابة فقط، والتعبير عن نفسه
يمكن هذا يخلينا نرجع نتأمل فكرة أو مسألة حرق الكتب، اللي حرقوا كتبهم
في ناس، وحتى في كتاب صغير كتبه أحد من الزملاء في...
مؤلف سعودي كتب: أن حرق الكتب في التراث العربي
أو في الثقافة العربية أو شيء زي كذا
لأن عبدالرحمن الآن أنت لما تتبع مثلًا معجم الأدباء «ياقوت الحموي»
آلاف موجودين
«ياقوت» في القرن الثامن الهجري تقريبًا معظمهم لا نعرفهم
معناه سؤال الجدوى حاضر
هؤلاء أدباء ولهم دواوين، كم واحد في عصر المتنبي؟
لا نعرف إلا عشرة أو خمسة عشر فقط
فالفكرة أن يأتي زمن...
مثلًا كتابات «النفري» ما كان أحد ينظر إليها باهتمام
كتابات الصوفية عمومًا، ما كان أحد ينظر إليها باهتمام
حتى جاءت حركة الحداثة «أدونيس» ومجلة شعر ومجموعة
ذهبوا وصلتوا الضوء على كتابات الصوفية كنمط من الشعر المختلف تمامًا
فهذا خاضع لعدة عوامل، لكن السؤال...
أذكر كلمة لـ«ريلكا» يقول: إذا كنت تستطيع العيش دون كتابة فافعل
لا تكتب إلا إذا كانت حياتك متوقفة على الكتابة
إذا تقدر تعيش، وتمشي أمورك...
لأن الكتابة ليست مسألة ترفيه، في ناس يأخذونها ترفيه فعلًا
لكن المبدع الحقيقي هي معاناة
«الفرزدق» يقول: يأتي علي وقت
وقلع ضرس أهون علي من قول بيت واحد من الشعر
«الفرزدق»
فمسألة الإبداع والخلق هذا مبحث كبير
لكن اللي استمروا سواءً عرفوا أو لم يعرفوا
ووجدوا مكافآت أو حوافز أو لم يجدوا
هؤلاء من اللي كلمهم «ريلكا»
أن هؤلاء كتبوا لأنهم لم يستطيعوا الحياة دون كتابة
وهل يفرق بين الناس اللي تكتب لأجل الكتابة
والناس التي تكتب لأجل دوافع خارجية؟
في شيء يسمونه الصدق الفني أو شيء بتعبير القدامى
أتوقع أن لها جانبين
وظيفة الفن نفسها، هل مع المدرسة التي تقول الفن للفن أو الفن للحياة؟
هذا سؤال معني بالأثر أو القيمة أو الناتج النهائي من الكتابة
لكن مسألة أن...
يعني الشاعر الجاهلي، لما نعود إليه، وأنا دائمًا حوله أدندن
هل كان يعلم أنه شعره سيصل إلى الآن؟
أظنه لم يكن يفكر في ذلك أبدًا، لأنه قالها للهواء، وقالها للفراغ
والتقطها راوية، شخص حفظها
فقالها في سمر مع آخر، فحفظها
فأخذها هذا السامر الثاني أو الثالث، وأنشدها في سوق عكاظ
فحفظها مجموعة من كل الجزيرة العربية
فأخذوها، وحملها الطائي إلى الشمال، وحملها الحجازي إلى الحجاز
وحملها الأحسائي إلى هجر، وحملها ذاك إلى العراق
وهذا إلى الشام، فانتشرت
لكن في الأساس هو قالها للفراغ، وقالها للمجهول
نابعة من داخله بحكمتها وبألمها وفخرها وبكل شيء
أنا متأكد أنه لم يكن يتخيل الناس تعيش 1500 سنة
وأنها ستترجم للغة الإنقليزية
وأنها سيصير في مهرجان امرؤ القيس ومهرجان الأعشى
وعن قريب مهرجان «طرفة بن العبد» هذا الإيمان
لذلك الشعر الجاهلي هو...
أنا وغيري كثير مغرمين فيه لأنه حقيقي
ومرتبط بالحياة، ومرتبط بالواقع يصف الأرض والناقة
يا رجل تفاصيل صغيرة جدًّا
ما أبغى أقول أنهم وصفوا حتى روث البهائم، كتبوا عنه في معلقاتهم
عجيب هذا الالتصاق بالأشياء
آثار القدر، وآثار الرماد
الكلب، يقول لك: فلان جبان الكلب، كما يقال
يعني أنه من الكرم أن الكلب لا ينبح على الأغراب
لأنه من كثر كرمه فهو معتاد على الناس الذين يجون البيت هذا
يدخلون، ويلقون الكرم
فالفكرة أنه في الكتابة
الذي يستمر هو شخص غير قادر على الحياة دون كتابة
أما الذي يستطيع تلاقيه يكتب فترة
وإذا ما لقى جائزة أو ما حصل كذا، قام يسب المشهد كله
وينتقد رجال التحكيم، ويكفر بالقضية كاملة
وأتوقع اللي يبقى فعلًا هو اللي يكتب، لأنه حقيقي ويُمثل شخصه
لكن أنت قلت قبل شوي وظيفة الفن
ودي أعرف، أيش وظيفة الفن؟
هل هي تعبير عن شخصك وعن حالك، أو تمثيل المجتمع؟
أيش وظيفة الفن؟
والله يا أخوي عبدالرحمن، الفن له وظائف مرة كثير
والفن خليني بس أقول: أنه الفن في حالة من الحالات يتحكم في الواقع
كيف؟
أنت لما تعمر بيت
كم نسبة حضور الفن في الموضوع، إجبار غصبًا عنك؟
كثير، مو بسيط
الفن أصبح، في أشياء احنا أخذناها الآن بشكل لا واعي
داخلة في قوانيننا وتقاليدنا وفهمنا للأشياء
نحكم الفن على الطبيعي والعادي والحياتي
مثلًا أن لو جاك في رواية أو في مسلسل أو في فلم
شخص طلع وصدمته سيارة
تقول: كذا جاءت السيارة صدمته؟
لا، هذا غير مبرر وهذا مباشرة، وتافه صح؟
وفي الواقع يصير وللا لا؟
يصير
مين اللي حكم على الآخر؟
الفن
شفت؟
الفن خطير، أي إنسان يقلل من قيمة الفن يجب أن نتشك في وعيه
عبدالرحمن، مشاكلنا في الحياة أغلبها من الفن، وليس من الواقع
كيف؟
يا أخي تشكلاتنا هي من مسلسلات الكرتون اللي كنا نشوفها
من أغاني التتر التي عشقناها، ومن الشخصيات التي ارتبطنا بها
وليس من التي تعلمناها في المدرسة، صح أم لا؟
هذه تضل تصحبك إلى ما لا نهاية
اللون واللعبة، وكل شيء هو اللي يتحكم فيك
ما أنت عليه اليوم هو حصيلة أشياء كثيرة
لكن أكثر من نصفها من الفنون
من قصص الجدًّات، ومن الأغاني التي تسمعها ومن التهويدات
ربما مليون درس أنت ما تتذكره، لكن قصة قالها لك معلم...
وأنا يمكن اشتغلت في التعليم
ما أحد من الشباب اللي تشرفت أني اشتغلت معهم
يتذكر مثلًا معلومة في الأدب وللا في النقد أو البلاغة
لكنه يتذكر القصة اللي حكيتها له
ويتذكر كيف كنت واقف في القاعة، ومتسند على الباب أو على السبورة
وأحكي القصة، ومؤثرة فيه إلى اليوم
فالفن أخطر مما نتصور
ولذلك دائمًا أقول: أن الفن، كلما أحيينا الفنون في الأجيال
كلما حظينا بأجيال مسالمة ومعطاءة وبنّاءة أكثر
فوظيفة الفن، يا عزيزي، من وظائفه فهم الذات أولاً
لما تكتب مشاعرك أنت تفهم نفسك أكثر
التنفيس عن ما في داخلك
تحتقن بفكرة أو بشعور ما أن تكتبه أو ترسمه أو تلحنه أو تدندنه
أنت هنا تخلصت منه بشكل أو بآخر
ووعيت أكثر بالمشكلة، ومن وظائفه الترفيه، جزء أساسي
ومن وظائفه التربية
كيف؟
القرآن مثلًا قصص بلا حدود بل أن القصة تعاد في كل مرة
ويسلط الضوء على مثلًا مكان أو على شخصية أو على حدث معين
نفس القصة، فعجيب
استخدم القصص لإرساء عقيدة وإرساء دين
هذا هنا أعلى من القيمة الجمالية مثلًا للسرد والحكاية
فله وظائف كثيرة الفن عمومًا
والفن أنا أشوفه قبلما نسأل هذه الأسئلة كلها
لا توجد حياة دون فنون، أبدًا
ليش الناس دائمًا تبغى، وخصوصًا الحين
أنا ما أدري قديمًا إذا موجودة أنت أدرى
بس حاليًا تلقى أن الناس تبغى الفن يمثل مو حقيقة واقعهم
وإنما ما يتمنون
فتلقى مثلًا هنا واحد زعلان على نجيب محفوظ
فيقول: من الذين نقلوا الصورة المشوهة للمرأة في المجتمع المصري
اللي هو نجيب يعني
فصورها فتاة الليل وصورها بالعاهرة وصورها بالعاشقة
أما صورة المرأة المكافحة العفيفة والفلاحة المصرية المجاهدة
لم تكن لها مكان في روايات النجيب محفوظ
فكان يبغى هذه الصورة، وما يبغى هذه الصورة
رغم أنه مجتمع في كل شيء أو ممكن جزء من خيال نجيب
في مطالبات الناس دائمًا
وتلقى مثلًا «بنات الرياض» يوم طلعت
كيف أن الناس انتقدتها، وأظن أنها منعت حتى، وعلى ذلك فقِس
كثير منها يطالب بأنها تنقل الصورة الحقيقية
وإذا أخذنا برضو الفن أبعد من الشعر والرواية إلى المسلسلات والأفلام
فتلقى المسلسلات السعودية والعربية
إذا تجاوزت الرقيب، بتلقى المشاهدين يزعلون جدًّا من أي مشهد
وإن كان حقيقي، بس يمثل المجتمع بصورة ما هي حلوة
فيقولون: يشوّه مجتمعنا
فبين هذا كله، كيف تشوف الفكرة؟
التلقي مشكلة
في تلقي أخلاقي أحيانًا أو ديني، خليني أقول إيديولوجي
بالمفهوم الشامل الإيديولوجي
اللي هو مثلًا نقول الموقف الفكري أيّا كان
كان إيديولوجيا اجتماعية أو سياسية أو دينية، أو أيًّا كانت
هذا التلقي هو اللي يحاكم أو يجعل النصوص تأخذ صور وآثار وأبعاد
حسب المتلقي
ربما النص هو أو الفن سواءً كان مسلسل أو رواية أو مسرحية أو فلم
هو منتج فني موازي ربما للواقع أو مخالف له
يمثل رؤية أو موقف الفنان اللي أنتجه
التلقي أفسد أو يستطيع أن يفسد حتى النصوص المقدسة
لماذا يحترب أو احتربت المذاهب؟ بسبب اختلاف في التلقي
لماذا تعددنا، وما بين كل المذاهب الأربعة الفقهية
السنة والشيعة والإباضية وغير الإسماعيلية ومعتزلة ومرجعة وقدرية
من وين؟ كلنا نعود ونستشهد بنصوص مقدسة
فمسألة التلقي مسألة في غاية الأهمية
الموضوع الآخر أن في منهج أو في خط يقول لك: أنه يجب أن توظف الفن
لغايات أخلاقية وتربوية ووطنية، هذا موجود
الآن في أثر لهذا، وهو أفق التوقع
أنا ماذا أتوقع من روائي زي مثلًا نجيب محفوظ؟
أتوقع أنه يبرز كذا وكذا، طيب والسلبيات؟
التلقي الأخلاقي أو التلقي الإديولوجي هو الذي يوقعنا في هذا
ونحن في الثقافة السعودية تعرضنا لهذا في أكثر من تجربة
أتذكر في الثمانينيات بدأت حركة الحداثة
وكان أغلبها أدبية ومخالية إلى حد كبير
من التوجه الفكري للحداثة في منابعها الأصلية
خرج مجموعة...، نحن كنا نتعرف تذكر فترة
اللي هي ما يسمى بالصحوة كانت هي الفكر المسيطر في تلك المرحلة
فظهر عندنا كتاب اسمه «الحداثة في ميزان الإسلام»
وبدأ يتحدث عن الحداثة الشعرية والأدبية في المملكة العربية السعودية
وكل الأسماء والرموز التي ساهمت فيها من موقف ديني تمامًا
الكتاب صادر عام 1409 تقريبًا
في عز الصراع ما بين المحافظين والحداثيين
المحافظين ومعهم الجانب الديني وحماة اللغة العربية الأصالة
والناس اللي يقولوا: أن هذا خط جديد في الكتابة، ومنفتح
وبدأت أن نكتب شعر عمودي أو لا؟
قصيدة أو شعر منثور أو تفعيلة أو غيره؟
فكان هذا الكتاب ضربة قوية جدًّا لكل المنجز الأدبي في تلك الفترة
تأذى بسببه حتى الأشخاص
الذين وردت أسماؤهم من أبناء وبنات الوطن
بسبب هذا الحكم الذي ورد في هذا الكتاب الذي لا علاقة له بالأدب
بل هو مراجعة أو محاكمة دينية للمنتج الأدبي
لها ما لها وعليها ما عليها
«بنات الرياض» وما إلى ذلك
ظهر كتاب آخر يُحاكم الرواية السعودية، اللي انفجرت من بعد 2001
بدأت تتحدث كتابات نسائية كثيرة عن موقع المرأة
وعن سيطرة بعض الأصوات الدينية المتشددة، وعلى الإرهاب
كانت مراجعة شاملة للذات السعودية
ثقافيًّا وفكريًّا واجتماعيًّا من خلال الرواية، وظهر كتاب يُحاكمها
بل أنه على طاري «بنات الرياض» ظهرت رواية ثانية بنفس الاسم تقريبًا
اسمها «فتاة الرياض»
يُظهر المرأة أو بنت الرياض بأنها إنسانة محافظة ومتدينة
هذا الصراع طبيعي جدًّا وموجود، ولن ينتهي
بوجهة نظري أنا أنه لن ينتهي طالما هناك اتجاهات فكرية ومصالح شخصية
تريد أن تختطف شيء لنفسها
مثلًا إذا رجعنا لقصة المتنبي كان سهمه في الطالع مع سيف الدولة
إلى أن تحرك مجموعة في بلاط الأمير، وقلبوا عليه الطاولة
وخرج مخذولًا دامي الوجه بعد أن رماه أحد الجالسين بمحبرة
أظن «بن خالويه الأديب» وخرج من بلاط سيف الدولة
إن كانَ سرَّكمُ ما قال حاسدُنا
فما لجُرح إذا أرضاكُمُ ألَمُ
فهذه الصراعات موجودة، ولكن يجب التعامل معها
برؤية ثقافية شاملة تتيح التعدد والاختلاف، ولكن في إطار محدد
بس مثلًا إذا أخذنا المجون مثلًا كمعيار أو واحدة من العناصر
هل كان زمان...
لأنها تجدها حتى في المعلقات
واللي يمكن تكون المعلقات كانت معلقة على ستار الكعبة أو غيرها
فتجدها
هل كانوا ينزعجون من هذا وللا هو حساسية أصبحت اليوم اتجاه المجون
ولا أتقبله شخصيًّا اتجاه مجتمعي أصبحت حادة اليوم؟
خلينا بس نوقف عند كلمة المجون، يا عبدالرحمن
لازم نتفق على مفهومها بالضبط
المجون كلمة واسعة جدًّا تبدأ من النكتة والمقالب والسخرية
إلى أن تصل إلى مثلًا التجاوزات الأخلاقية أو الممارسات الأخلاقية
غير الخارجة عن حدود المقبول
هذا كله اسمه مجون
الثقافة العربية حافلة بمدونات تفرغت لهذه السرديات
سواءً ما فيها من هزل وسخرية وفكاهة بل هناك مباحث كثيرة جدًّا
وفي رسائل عن الفكاهة في الأدب العربي
وهناك كتب تحدثت عن ما يسمى أو ربما يصنف في الفحش الأخلاقي
وبعض الممارسات غير المقبولة، وهي موجودة
وبل أسهم فيها حتى بعض المتدينيين من الفقهاء وغيرهم
وهي موجودة سواءً في مؤلفات مستقلة متخصصة في هذا الجانب
أو تأتي ضمن أبواب الكتاب
الذي يبدأ بآيات قرآنية وأحاديث ومواعظ
ثم يتجه إلى الأخلاق والآداب والمواعظ والحكام والسلطان وصحبة كذا
ويتجه إلى أبواب المجون، ويختم بها
لا أعرف أنا في حد علمي المتواضع جدًّا
لا أعرف أن هناك كاتبًا أو مثقفًا في الثقافة العربية القديمة
حُوكم بسبب مثل هذه الكتابات
يحاكم أو يحاسب بسبب أشياء عقدية
زي مثلًا الصراع بين السنة والمعتزلة في عصر المتوكل والمعتصم وهؤلاء
أو أشياء سياسية أو مواثيق كتبها زي «ابن المقفع»
لكن يُتّهم بالزندقة وليس لهذا، هذا ربما يكون جزء
لكن السبب الأساسي أنه انحرافات عقدية، وخاصة مع الأعراق المختلفة
الثقافة العربية القديمة كانت أكثر تسامحًا مع كتابات الهزل والفكاه والمجون
من ثقافتنا المعاصرة
والحق أن هذا خط من خطوط أو اتجاه من اتجاهات الكتابة القديمة
وموجود في الشعر وغيره
الحكم الأخلاقي في زاوية من الزوايا أو في مستوى من المستويات
يجب أن يكون حاضر
لأن هذا الأدب يجب أن يصنف لمثلًا فئة معينة مثلًا أدب الفتيان أو الأطفال
يجب أن يُلقّن مثل هذه الأشياء
أما أنه غير موجود في الثقافة العربية
فأنا أظن أنه موجود وسيظل موجود
والناس تختلف في تلقيهم بين قبول ورفض
ويمكن الأدوات تختلف اليوم مثلًا لما يصبح...
أتوقع أن لليوم ما تزال الروايات عندها هذه المساحة الأعلى منها
في الأفلام والمسلسلات وللا؟
التلقي زي ما أقول لك: عجيب
ممكن تقبلها في رواية لكن إذا صارت على الشاشة ما تقبلها
مستوى المباشرة أو مستوى التجسيد لغويًّا يختلف عن التجسيد من ممثلين
لكن خلني أقول لك شغلة
قُل
في الأعمال الفنية والأدبية تستطيع أن تمرر كثير من الأفكار
بتسامي لغوي وبذكاء حرفي سواءً في الفن أو التمثيل حتى
بدون أن تُكاشف أو تكون مباشر في مثل هذه الأشياء
أحيانًا يكون مثل هذا العنصر هو الهدف من الكتابة أو المسلسل أو الفلم
وهذا يأتي إلى الإباحية أو المباشرة أو في الأدب
مثلًا أدب مكشوف، كما يقال
ما الغرض منه، وهل فيه غاية جمالية أو إنسانية أو اجتماعية؟ لا أعلم
موضوع ثاني، ممكن أحيانًا أنا بس أعبر عن نفسي، صح؟
وأنت كنت تقول أن هذا جزء من كتابة
الذات
أو من تجربة معينة أو أي شيء
ولذا الفنان يصبح فنان من هذا الجانب
سواءً في الأدب وللا الكتابة وللا الرسم وللا غيرهم
هل هذا الحين يمثله هو شخصيًّا، وللا يمثل المجتمع؟
ليش الناس دائمًا تقول أنه يُمثل المجتمع؟
أو يُشوه المجتمع أو أيًّا يكن؟
هذه مسألة نسبية هو في الحقيقة أن الفنان لا يمثل إلا نفسه، أبدًا
الكاتب الروائي لا يُمثل إلا نفسه
وصارت عندنا مثلًا كتاب «خواطر مصرحة»
لـ«محمد حسن عواد» الله يرحمه
عمر الكتاب تسعين سنة أو أكثر
وصل الأمر إلى المطالبة بإعدامه
الآن لو تقرأ الكتاب تقول: عجيب، لأجل هذا؟
في بعض الأفكار اللي هي مثلًا تعليم المرأة
رغبة في وجود شخصية مستقلة للشاب السعودي
في بدايات توحيد السعودية كان هذا الكلام
«خواطر مصرحة» يعتبر كتاب مُجرّم
ولكن قلت لك: هذه الصراعات ما راح نخلص منها أبدًا، وستظل موجودة
وستزداد متى ما تدخل غير أهل الأدب في حرفة الأدب
شلون؟ مو توك تقول: كل الناس تقدر تسوي اللي تبغاه؟
تقرأ بس ما تفتي
شلون؟
الأدب أحيانًا يكون الحيط المائل
كل الناس تتكلم في الأدب، بس الأديب ما يُسمح له يتكلم في الطب
صحيح
ليه طيب؟
أيش العلاقة؟ هذا موضوع مختلف، وهذه مسألة إنسانية
كونه يكون عندي رأي سواءً في الفن وللا الأدب وللا غيره
ممتاز رأي، ما تفتي
ما تجي تقول: نجيب محفوظ أساء لكذا أو فلان جنى على الرواية كذا
وتصدّر...
أنا أقدر أقول: والله مثلًا البندول مثلًا في كذا، وأنا أديب ما لي علاقة
أتكلم عن مكوناته
أنا أقول: أعجبتني الرواية جميلة، اقرؤوها
بس والله الموضوع مختلف مرة يا أبو شادن
لأنه الحيط المائل، الأدب
لا، الموضوع إنساني
يعني المواضيع الإنسانية تختلف عن المواضيع العلمية التطبيقية
الذائقة وابداء الرأي...
لكن تجي وتفتي، نقول لك: تفتي، وتصدر أن هذا أساء للمجتمع أو لا
لما جاء ذاك إلى عمر بن الخطاب
وعمر بن الخطاب من أعلم الناس بالشعر، ما أفتاه
قال له: روح لـ«لحسّان»
شفت؟
واحد جاي يقول: فلان هجاني، اللي هو «الزبرقان بن بدر» هجاه
أظنه «الحُطيئة»
يقولون: اللي ما بقى أحد ما هجاه، يعني لعب...
قال له: «دَعِ المَكارِمَ لا تَرحَل لِبُغيَتِها
وَاِقعُد فَإِنَّكَ أَنتَ الطاعِمُ الكاسي»
يعني تأكل وتشرب
الآن طاعم وكاسي، يعني ممكن تكون مُطْعِم
وممكن تكون أنت مُطْعَم، فعمر ما أفتى
مع أنه أكيد أن عنده القدرة لكن هو ما هو أديب وناقد أدب
حوّله على الشاعر
أنا هذا اللي أقول: أن الجميع يُفتي في الأدب
لإبداء الرأي حسنًا، أعجبني أو ما أعجبني
جميل أو رديء أو الشخصية والإيقاع، حسنًا
زي ما تبدي رأيك في الموسيقى
زي ما أُبدي رأيي أنا في الطبيب أو المستشفى
بس في الأدوية وفي الإجراءات العلاجية
ولا في التمارين الرياضية كم تلعب عدّة «باي» وكم «تراي»
احنا الأُدباء مو مسموح لنا، وأنتم أيضًا...
عفوًا، غير المختص في الأدب لا يتدخل بهذا الشكل
لن أتدخل
لا
لأن الأدب مو شيء سهل
مو كل واحد يستطيع أن يفتي فيه
بل يا عبدالرحمن، خليني أرجع لمسألة...سألت عن المجون
قبل خمسين سنة في بلدنا حكايات الجدات والأجداد
متسامحة أكثر مع هذه الأشياء، صح أم لا؟
وأكيد ذاكرتك وذاكرة الجميع تختزن أشياء
وتُحكى بشكل طبيعي جدًّا، لأنها حياة طبيعية
إلى حد معين، فيه تسامح
التشدد يأتي مع الإديولوجيا ومع الموقف سواءً الأخلاقي
أو الديني أو غيره من هذه الأشياء
بل أنه، اللهم صلّي وسلم على محمد قصة «كعب بن زهير» يا رجل
شهيرة جدًّا، عندما جاء ودمه مهدور
وجاء متخفيا إلى بيت أبي بكر، فأخذه إلى المسجد، القصة مشهورة
لم يتنازل «كعب بن زهير» عن تقاليد الشعر والفن
وبدأ بمقدمة ذكر فيها غزل وأوصاف غزلية عن «سعاد»
فيها أوصاف للجسد، وفيها كذا
ولم يتحدث الرسول بأي انتقاد سلبي
بل أكرمه بأن ألبسه البُردة، وانتشرت هذه القصيدة جدًّا
فأقصد أن الفكر والوعي
حتى في القرآن «وَالشُّعَرَاءُ يَتَّبِعُهُمُ الْغَاوُونَ»
مو معنى أنهم...
في فرق بين التخييل
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لو قيل هذا الكلام أمامه في أوصاف «سعاد»
لامرأة موجودة بشكل حقيقي، لن يكون مقبولًا هذا الكلام
لكن لأنه تخييل، ما معنى تخييل؟
إنشاء مُتخيّل، كلام غير واقعي، إنما هو مُتخيّل
ومسألة التخييل هذه مسألة مختلفة عن مسألة الخيال
إنما التخييل هو بناء عوالم موازية للعالم الواقعي في أبسط صور المفهوم
فما تحدث إليه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم أبدًا
بل أنه نصب لـ«حسّان» منبرًا
أو كان يقول: منبر في المسجد يُلقي عليه الشعر
وفي الرواية لما دخل عمر في خلافته وهو الخليفة
و«حسان» يُلقي قصيدة في المسجد
فقال: أعلى منبر رسول الله أو في مسجد رسول الله يا «حسان»؟
فقال له: اجلس يا عمر، فقد كنت أنشده، وفينا من هو خيرٌ منك
الخيرية هنا في القيمة المقدسة للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وفي الوعي في مسألة الفن والشعر
على الفن، في عندنا الرواية وفي عندنا الرواية السعودية
كنت تقول أن الرواية السعودية: هي رواية الآخر بامتياز
وين قلت الكلام هذا أنا؟
وين قلته، ليش مو كذا؟
إلا قلت
أيش تقصد، وأي حقبة تتكلم عنها؟
هذا الكلام أنا أشوفه في وجهة نظري أن الرواية السعودية كلها
ليه رواية الآخر بامتياز؟
لأن أول رواية نبتت في السعودية كانت متجهة إلى الآخر
من تقصد الآخر؟
إذا تبغى نتكلم في هذا الموضوع
فالآخر تحول وتغير، وهذا طبيعي
لكن بدأت الرواية، في هذه إجابة على سؤالك، من هو الآخر؟
كان الآخر الخارج، الآخر الغربي تحديدًا
الرواية هذه صدرت أثناء الحقبة الاستعمارية
في بداية الثلاثينيات الميلادية اللي هي «التوأمان» لـ«عبدالقدوس الأنصاري»
هذه ظهرت في مرحلة كانت حول المملكة العربية السعودية
الوطن العربي تقريبًا أجزاء كثيرة منه كلها تحت الاستعمار
وربما هنا يظهر سؤالي عن السعودية، ما لها علاقة بالاستعمار، صحيح
لكن المواطن السعودي هو مواطن عربي في الأساس
وهمه ديني وقومي موجود
فتنبأ «عبدالقدوس الأنصاري» إلى وجود بعض
آثار الاستعمار الفكرية الظلال أو الأفق الثقافي والأخلاقي للاستعمار
فكتب هذه الرواية
وكتب مقدمة ربما تُعادل أهميتها أهمية الرواية
أن احنا الآن نكتب هذه الرواية لنرد أو نتحدث مع الغرب بفن غربي
الرواية فن غربي في الأساس
شئنا أم أبينا هي جنس أدبي جاي من الغرب
ولم يكن موجود في الثقافة السعودية
وحتى في الثقافة العربية
ترى الرواية المصرية ما سبقت الرواية السعودية إلا بسنوات بسيطة
اللي هي رواية «زينب»
وهي فن آخر أساسًا دخيل على الشعر، منافس للشعر
وفن مُحتقر غير محترم، لم تكن الرواية محترمة
حتى في الغرب ما كانت محترمة الرواية
إلى الخمسينيات الميلادية أو خلّنا نقول النصف الأول من القرن الماضي
ما كانت محترمة الرواية
حتى أنه صاحب أول رواية عربية ما كتب اسمه عليها
ليه؟
كتب فلّاح مصري على الغلاف
لأن العقاد هجى الرواية والروائيين
وهذه الرواية «التوأمان» اللي كتبها «الأنصاري»
سلخها «محمد حسن عواد» بشكل غير طبيعي نسفها نسف
وصارت بينهم ردود حول هذا، وصلت إلى تجريح شخصي
لذلك أقول لك: الصراعات هذه ما راح تنتهي أبدًا
فكتب هذه، ووضح في مقدمة الرواية
أنه لأجل الرد على الغرب أو على هذه الأفكار بجنس لغتهم والفنون اللي...
فكان تصريح من الكاتب أن أنا كتبتها لأتحدث مع هذا الآخر الخارجي
واستمرت في ثلاثين سنة لاحقة لا تتحدث إلا عن هذه الأشياء
هي ما كانت كثير فعلًا
لكن عندنا شيء يسمونه البداية التاريخية للرواية
اللي هي «التوأمان» تتحدث عن الآخر
وكانت فنيًّا كما يقولون: أنها غير ناضجة: كما يقول النقاد
يوم جاءت الرواية الناضجة مع «حامد دمانهوري» في 1959
اسمها «ثمن التضحية»
هي تعتبر الرواية الفنية الأولى في السعودية
أيضًا كانت تتحدث عن الآخر
وهي حكاية شاب راح مصر ودرس فيها، أيضًا خارج الوطن
آخر لكن آخر عربي، وتعلم
استمر هذا الكلام تمامًا مع الرواية السعودية بشكل موجز
أن جاءت حركة الابتعاث فيما بعد فظهرت عندنا رواية تتحدث عن الابتعاث
رواية «السنيورة» و«لحظة ضعف»
اللي بيئتها في إيطاليا، واللي بيئتها في فرنسا
واللي بيئتها في هذه الدول
في التسعينيات هنا بدأت الرواية تُفتّش عن الآخر القريب
ليه؟
لأن بدأ المكون الهوياتي أو سؤال الهوية يظهر
عند المثقف أو المواطن السعودي
قلت لك وتحدثنا في البداية: حرب الخليج والصحوة
وأحداث إحدى عشر سبتمبر، والإسلام والغرب والعرب
حتى الوعي بالذات السعودية
وعي السعودي بذاته المستقلة أمام الذوات العربية الأخرى كان مهم
تعرف أن في بدايات الحلم العربي بأمة عربية واحدة، وهذه الوعود
والعنتريات، وأن راح نفعل ونفعل، ودولة يعني أمة عربية واحدة
كان في نظرة سلبية اتجاه الخليج
بل أن بعض المفكرين العرب يقولها، وكتبها في أكثر مثلًا من مؤتمر أو كتاب
أن ثروات الخليج أو النفط الخليجي
هو سبب من أسباب إجهاض حلم الأمة العربية
ويوم جاءت أزمة الخليج وضعت الأمر بشكل واضح
كيف أن بعض الدول صارت ضد دول الخليج وضد الكويت، وضد السعودية
وهم جيراننا ما هم بعيدين، فهنا صارت هزة حقيقية
الحروب والأزمات هذه فعلًا، وين تروح؟
تروح أفلام ومسلسلات وروايات وقصائد ومقالات
مين كان الآخر في هذه الحقبة؟
مبدئيًّا في البدايات كان الآخر الغربي
زي ما قلت لك في الثلاثينيات والخمسينيات إلى الثمانينيات
العربي؟
بالتسعينيات بدأ الآخر العربي
شقة الحرية كلها تتكلم عن العهد الناصري
ثلاثية «تركي الحمد» الشهيرة «أطياف الأزقة المهجورة»
اللي «العدامة» و«الشميسي» و«الكراديب»
كلها تتحدث عن تجربة هشام العابر في حزب البعث
مع شوية ناصرية على شوية بعض الأفكار الماركسية
«عبدو خال» كمان في «مدن تأكل العشب»
تكلم عن الحقبة الناصرية
وأشار في روايته إلى ضرب جمال عبد الناصر لمنطقة جيزان في أيام حرب اليمن
فظهر الآخر العربي بعدما كان الآخر الغربي مسيطر شوية
وهي أعداد الروايات أصلًا قبل التسعينيات جدًّا محدودة
صدر إلى قبل الـ1995 عشرات الروايات ثلاثين أو أربعين، إي ما في
والأسماء محدودة
جاءت في الـ 1995 و1994 يعني التسعينيات عمومًا
بدأت خاصة مع هؤلاء الثلاثة
أنا أقدر أقول: تركي الحمد و«عبدو خال» و«غازي القصيبي»
بدأت الكتاب الرواية تنضج جدًّا، وتعالج الآخر العربي
ثم الآخر السعودي الآخر المحلي
الذات لها أكثر من مكون
مُكون اجتماعي قبلي، مُكون جندري ذكر وأنثى
مكون مذهبي سنّة وشيعة
مكون جغرافي، ومكون فكري محافظين وحداثيين أو ليبراليين
هذه كلها ظهرت اليوم بشكل واضح جدًّا بعد أحداث إحدى عشر سبتمبر
والحرب على الإرهاب، وإعلان...
حتى عندنا في البلد هزت المجتمع السعودي، فبدأ صوت المرأة
وهذا كله نتيجة التعليم، ونتيجة الاستقرار والطفرة والابتعاث
الجامعات والإعلام والإنترنت
كل هذه أدت إلى أن...
يقولون: أن المجتمعات البسيطة ما عندها أزمة هوية
متطابقة ومتسامحة مع أنفسها
المجتمعات اللي تصير فيها تنوع وثراء، وشئ من الصراع أو الاختلاف
تبحث عن سؤال الذات والآخر
لأن البلد الواحد ليس طيفًا واحدًا
بل أن ربما الآخرية الداخلية على مر التاريخ هي الأكثر مثلًا
الحرب العالمية قامت بين مَن؟
في أوربا كأنها حرب أهلية
الوحدة الحضارية هل منعت الحرب؟
الوحدة الدينية ووحدة اللغة والمكان، ما منعوا الحرب
ما نُبرئ الساحة الشرقية
الغرب والشرق كلهم كانت الاحترابات
فبدأ سؤال الهوية السعودي وانطلق، وجاء في الرواية
بس مع الآخر القريب
فوجدنا الرجل آخر للمرأة، والمرأة آخر للرجل
وجدنا القبيلي وغير القبيلي
وجدنا الحجازي والنجدي والحساوي والجيزاني والقصيمي، وجدنا هذه
وجدنا الطبقات الاجتماعية
وجدنا السود ملونين ضد الأبيض
وجدنا أصحاب الحرف، اللي لهم تسمية أظن عندنا موجودة
وجدنا هذه كل الطبقات الاجتماعية، وُجدَت
في الرواية السعودية؟
طبعًا
روايات كثيرة خاصة الصوت النسوي أو التيار النسوي
صعد بقوة في هذه الفترة من بعد الـ2000 إلى 2010
وكان فيه اهتمام نقدي كبير، واهتمام إعلامي كبير
وزي ما قلت لك: كان أكثر من 100 رواية سنويًّا تصدر في المملكة العربية السعودية
وتراجع الشعر جدًّا في هذه المرحلة، وأصبح الناس يتجهون للرواية
حتى دور النشر لا تعبأ بالديوان الشعري، وتتجه لطباعة الروايات
فاستمرت الرواية رواية الآخر، ولكن الآخر القريب
وهذا كان مفيد جدًّا في الوعي بالذات
أسئلة الانشطارات أو الانقسامات الداخلية
هذه الانقسامات اللي الدولة السعودية تحتويها كلها
وبحكمة المؤسس، الله يرحمه، استوعبت كل هذه الاختلافات
وبلورتها في هوية اسمها الهوية السعودية
عبدالرحمن عندنا الهوية السعودية تعرضت لمشاكل كثيرة
تعرضت إما لاختطاف أو لإلغاء أو لتشويه أو لتعمية
يا أخي البلد كبلد ناشئ تبدأ عبقرية المؤسس، الله يرحمه
في كيف استنقذ هذه البقعة الكبيرة الجغرافية من أنياب القوى الكبيرة؟
التأسيس تم في عهد «موسوليني» وعهد هتلر
وفي عهد الإمبراطورية يعني الفاشية والنازية والشيوعية
والملك عبد العزيز مسك الجزيرة العربية، وهذا شيء خرافي جدًّا
كيف؟
ليس بالإقصاء، ولا فقط بالحرب أو بالـ...
بل بالعكس بالحفاظ على هذه المكونات واستثمارها
هنا الهوية الحقيقية التي كانت أيام الملك عبد العزيز اللي من بعده
ومن بعد بعض الظروف اللي صارت في البلد
أُختطفت هذه الهوية، وشُوّهت وغبشت
إلى أن جاء عهد الملك سلمان، الله يطول عمره
والقائد العظيم الأمير محمد بن سلمان
اللي أظهر الهوية السعودية، وأعادها إلى ما هي عليه فعلًا
أنا أجد أن كلمة السعودية الجديدة ليست دقيقة
هي السعودية الحقيقية اللي أزال عنها الغبش الأمير محمد بن سلمان
وبدل أن كانت...
المواطن السعودي في كل مكان يرد على الأسئلة، ويرد على الانتقادات
بأن دولتكم...
الآن أصبحنا نفخر بمكونات لم نكن ننتبه إليها إلا أنها هي اللي تكوننا
أصبحنا الآن نفتخر بقهوة أو بتطريز أو برقصة أو بلحن أو بموقع أثري
هذه هي الأشياء التي تصنعنا
الذي نبهنا إليها، وأعادنا إليها الأمير محمد بن سلمان
وهذه الرؤية العظيمة للسعودية
بدل أن تكون هذه المقومات في الجنوب والشمال والوسط والشرق والغرب
مكونات اختلاف واحتراب أصبحت مكونات ثراء ومكونات قوة وتنوع
يدل على أن هنا أمة سعودية حضارية
ما بين تلك الذات الموزعة
أصبح الآن كبار اللاعبين العالميين يلبسون البشت السعودي
ويحاولون يتكلمون اللهجة السعودية العربية
تمامًا كما في عصور الحضارة العربية الكبرى
هذا كان فقط يحتاج إلى قائد عبقري مثل محمد بن سلمان
لأن المواطن والإنسان جاهز
فقط كيف تُنقّي الذات والهوية السعودية
من كل الشوائب اللي اختطفتها في فترة من الفترات؟
وكيف نقتنع ونؤمن أن الوطن ليس مجرد كلام مباشر عن الوطن فقط؟
الفن مواطنة والبناء مواطنة، وريادة الأعمال مواطنة
والرياضة والموسيقى والآداب والفنون والمسرح والاقتصاد والاتصالات
وثورة المعلومات كلها هذه تصب في المكوّن أو المكونات الهوياتية
اللي احنا اليوم نعيش مرحلة لم تكن مسبوقة من قبل
الله يعطيك العافية
تسلم
شكرًا جزيلًا
شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لأيمن الحمادي في إعداد الحلقة
ووهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات
وفي التسجيل الصوتي: عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن
والتحرير: محمد نور شمت
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي: نورة السبيعي
وفي التلوين: عبد المجيد العطاس
في إدارة التحرير: أسيل باعبدالله
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل ألقاكم